[Music]
you made it weird with pete holmes
what's happening weirdos yes this is a
big deal this is the uh first video
episode we've ever done and i couldn't
be more thrilled that it is with maya
rudolph who is unbelievable you are
about to see how incredible she is
couldn't be a better first guest and uh
for those of you who have listened to
our podcast we've been out for 10 years
katie
more it might be more we don't keep
track but we're in the 400s of episodes
we're in the 600s i'm not good with time
but we've had 600 episodes and we're
just making the jump to youtube so
welcome hopefully to a new audience and
welcome to the fans of the podcast who
just have always wanted to see the the
studio this is just my garage we like to
do it like a sleepover style like we're
just on the same big uh pretty dirty but
cozy couch uh this is the backdrop from
my old talk show the pete holm show on
on tbs uh and this this is a painting i
had it's not a painting it's a print i
had made of ryan gosling so
so we're sitting under the gosling what
else can i tell you this is earthquake
food that i covered hastily with a
blanket um the treadmill's right here it
often gets in the shot
uh the sauna's over there but anyway
welcome to the show i'm so excited
you're here
just as always a couple things to plug
up top june 11th is my only stand-up
date right now if you'd like to see me
do stand-up at largo
they're always incredible shows the last
one we had rory scoville before that we
had uh mullany amy schumer we've had
adam sandler it's always incredible
regardless of who's there but it's
always me and it's always always really
really fun so go to largo
dash dashla.com for tickets to that and
if you like the show why not support the
show by trying a pete's pick uh trying
some one of our delightful sponsors like
our friends at living libations living
libations is an incredible
natural
high-end skin
hair beauty product line this in our
house everything is living libations uh
we have teeth care we have baby care
every morning we we slather our daughter
in sunscreen and i wanted to get her the
highest
and most natural
ingredients that you recognize and
effective sunscreen because so many
sunscreens are just filled with
chemicals and toxicity levels that were
never intended for human beings i
certainly don't want to put that on
myself i really really don't want to put
that on my baby girl so we've got the
love the sun zinc based natural like
really you can read the ingredients and
you're like okay okay okay okay there's
no like what the hell is that it's
wonderful and it works it keeps her from
getting sunburned every single day and
we know we're not putting something on
her skin that's going to absorb into her
blood and do god knows what
we have that every night i put on the
best skin ever moisturizer
i use their zen shave lotion which is a
shaving balm which is so moisturizing
and natural you can actually use it as
your aftershave try and do that doing
that with like an anonymous blue goo you
getting a pressurized can at 7-11 and
actually don't do that that's a terrible
idea what i'm saying is this is a great
way to support the show because whatever
product you're trying to replace with a
natural alternative i promise living
libations has a badass effective
wonderful alternative to replace the
chemical chemical nightmare you may be
getting at your pharmacy so if you want
to give it a try and support the show go
to livinglibations.com
and at checkout use promo code it's
different every month this month it's
weird 44
and show your support of the show do
your body do your skin your hair your
teeth your eyes a favor go to
livinglibations.com and use promo code
weird44
at checkout for 15 off
also
one of our oldest and longest running
pete's picks is alpha brain from our
friends at on it
literally just we just did an episode
with mike showalter and before the
episode you're about to see with maya i
always always always take two or three
alpha brain 15 minutes before for those
of you who don't know alpha brain is a
pneuotropic it's earth-grown ingredients
it is not a stimulant it's not like
caffeine it doesn't get you all jacked
up it just gives your brain the earth
grown nutrition that it needs to
function at its highest level we're
talking recall memory focus i really
wish i knew about alpha brain when i was
in school but i'm so glad i know about
it now i never do stand up i never write
a script i never act i never do a
podcast i never do late night whatever
i'm doing and whatever you're doing if
it involves your brain alpha brain just
helps your noodle work at its highest
peak level it's like fish food for
creativity for your mind like i said it
doesn't keep you awake in fact sometimes
i take it before bed because it gives me
really really groovy dreams that i have
an easier time remembering but i promise
it has been a secret weapon of mine for
over 10 years i love it it's in my car
it's in my travel bags it's in the
pockets of my coats and my shirts i
never leave home without it if you like
it one one-tenth as much as i do you're
gonna [__] your pants and you can show
your support of the show go to on it
onnit.com
weird everything on that page not just
alpha brain everything on that landing
page you will get 10 off and you will
show your support of the show so thank
you on it go to onit.com
slash weird
yeah i didn't say slash weird the first
time on it dot com slash weird and use
promo code weird at checkout for 10
off and and give it a give it a whirl i
hope you like it it's literally changed
my life all right everybody hope to see
you on june 11th
in the meantime at largo enjoy our first
our debut video episode with the
incredible
maya rudolph
get into it so this is you like just get
soups cuz
oh seems cold get soup
not soup's coves
didn't you just have i did just have
soups cocoa how was it um were you in
love with the coconut
[Music]
i love to call it the cocoa though i
also call it the cocoa i know someone
was saying roro and i was like uh uh is
the cocoa you don't call it roro
yeah retro sounds a little too close to
like an asian lr joke oh it's straight
but it's scooby-doo
yeah it goes it instantly makes me
giggle because i look i think of
scooby's face well you've been to lady
largo yes ma'am
and there's a big sign that says rut ro
it's it's well you know a good landmark
is the portrait of my face look i'm
proud of that oh
are you one of the portraits in the back
guess who brought it
this guy
this guy this guy that you're pointing
to i brought i brought and you know we
were talking about pta and i told myself
that i would have no pta questions and
that's no it's fine did you really have
to like
well so you know whenever there's a
guest my can i call you my
yeah what else would you call me
i just don't know
i have known like real nicknames except
for my is great my is cute i like when
people call me mai it actually makes me
feel warm it's i well that's what i'm
going to say i or my my people call me
maya is also wonderful yeah um i was
rudy a little bit in high school
i wasn't i think the holidays were for
how were the christmas holidays for for
rudy
for rudolph oh for the rudolph's yeah
why because we're maya the rudolph you
know rudolph my
oh i [__] love it
i
i you like the rudolph attention the
attention
isn't that weird like when i was a kid
the kids would be like
rudolph and i was like yeah
i like it
and isn't that the difference what i
don't like is how
often it is misspelled yeah it's a
pretty famous song
and
christmas special it's a hit song it's a
hit if we it's like a it's a banger if
we have to be honest and people spell it
with an f left and right
it's not an f but
it's technically it's arbitrary because
i did my genealogy and rudolph isn't
even the real name well it's uh
ashkenazi it's lithuanian lithu you know
who's a lithuanian this guy the guy who
brought the portrait of himself to largo
do you know where you're from i texted i
did a little re
search
[Music]
what's happening kind of a creepy but
sincere
search oh wait till i i have a wink
story for you don't let me forget okay
look i'll write it down
i have a i really [__] up with a
creepy wink story there's a lot of
creepy wink and i love to wink we're not
gonna forget wink yeah i also love a
good like if you need a breakfast in my
teeth no i didn't check no no
and if i did no one would care no i just
ate at all time because i love it so
much where do we go
did you have a red bearded gentleman
that greeted you no that's reuben if
yeah no it was a lady and she did not
have a red oh that's ruben nina oh god
you're great you're wonderful thank you
for they don't make the adventure bread
anymore and it was my favorite
we don't have as many ops at that at all
time although i do like it
the coffee is really good the coffee's
great i just had the coffee and i had a
dish called the boat yeah we know the
boat it's it's it's delightful we know
the boat we get in the boat lithuanian
well the i i'm vegan i'm mostly veg but
i'll eat the cheesy egg bread which is
not vegan which means i'm not a vegan so
you're going through that you're a ch
you're you're a vegan a choice female
i'm a cheagan
i like to say i'm a flu look
i definitely have the feeling of a
chicken like if i say i'm a vegan most
people in their minds are just like not
all the time uh paul's vegan look at
this guy really yeah pta pt animal tea
pt animal robert
wait peter
thomas sanders oh my god it is
i have a feeling it is only just begun
do you guys know each other well that's
what i was going to tell you my
embarrassing pta story oh please because
not just you
but if um i'm trying to think
if somebody has a famous relationship or
something i
i can't come to a mind with an example
like like burt and lonnie bert and
lonnie like burt reynolds and lonnie
anderson but neither of them
it's the first one
i'm trying to think if somebody's on the
podcast and there's the thing
and you don't want to bring it like if i
was angelina yeah don't bring up brad
don't bring up don't bring up bread
we'll also they are divorced maybe you
don't are they i can't keep up i really
who really knows
i always but if it was i'm trying to
think of like a like a real hot
hot couple celeb couple katie can you
think of it yeah why am
and just the first one that comes to
mind is um uh j.lo and ben
i did it
and they're back they're back and
they're back too i should have said
benefit i apologize jennifer have you
seen benny's back tattoo i have not have
you met ben yes you must have well yes i
mean many times not since the back
tattoo not since the back to you know
the back tattoo no
okay well give it a [__] like it oh
i've never seen him take his shirt off
turn that safe search off and go ahead
and give it a good you don't need safe
search keep my safe search on he has
i know that about you you don't want to
see a wayward nipple when you're just
looking for mountain ranges
this uh he has a very very full back
sort of
uh people are calling it like a midlife
crisis sort of tattoo is it of jlo
i mean
there's a wood her butt fit joke that i
don't want to make
that but it's a beautiful bum it's a
beautiful bum oh i'm saying it in a
positive way
i'm saying like it's
exciting
it's a peach it's a can i say it's a
peach it's a beautiful okay it's also
natural which i i love no implants in
the gym i love nature
nature
a lot that's a great way to get like
your weird uncle involved in nature like
j lo's butt is nature i couldn't love
that more give me a natural booty any
day but we think of like fields of
clover that's nature but jlo's butt is
also nature well yes because of the
predominant
non-natural buttocks that there are a
lot of implant butts oh my
oh my
pete what are we gonna do oh my god
there's so many i don't know oh garsh i
feel like no no you know what i feel
like i feel like men are supposed to say
i can tell
no one can tell you know what's weird
about me i am so
visual
i'm visual visual visual baby like about
everything i can
do this i i know all things you learn
visual you mean i definitely learn
visually i i draw i love clothing i
i can't think of all the the
things but i'm pornography
but i can't i'm really bad at telling
when someone's had work done and i don't
know why that is because i'm i'm great
like i'll remember your face i'll never
remember your name but i will you know
to all all of us uh i'll join you can't
spot a wig
and you know what same well wigs are
really good right now with if they are
excellent if they're front lace wigs
they're extra i just did a movie where
they made me a wig because arbitrarily i
was like i don't want to cut my covet
here just like on a whim good for you
you know what you know what good for you
[__] them [__] them and they're scissors
but the guy uh the woman forgive me that
did it
did krazynski's wig do you know the
krezinski wig story no krazynski wanted
to shut you we're talking about john
krasinski's hollow mug to the camera
john chrysome
those are given that's my camera i just
figured they were going to take pictures
of us at some point but i just realized
there's a main camera it's a matrix so
when we pull it so if i go backwards yes
and i'll shoot my agent
forget it listen just forget the whole
let's delete it and start again i don't
mind well oh krazynski wanted to cut his
hair for some movie gotcha this is at
the height of the office and remember
how we all love this sure the chris
cuisine the little peekaboo the ski the
the ski yeah it's krizin and then it's
ski
and it's a little flying nun yes and we
loved it yes it was the 90s the door it
was the early times it was totes
adorable but we loved it yeah we were we
were we were wet when we were wet and we
were hard when we were hard
i'm so i'm so sorry but i'm not so we
were when we were wet and we were hard
when we were hard the opening line of a
book i definitely need to read
we were
[Laughter]
don't know why i keep making fart noises
other than that i always make fart
noises and i make wet fart noises
i love it can i tell you something i
said about so you met vel yes she's the
best the best clearly the best clearly
the best or simply i mean
i said to val recently i said you know
when you fart and you can tell
on the toilet and you can tell
the depth of the toilet and how much
water is in it
oh my god you're making me think of
you know
like sonar no one has to
acknowledge that but we all know that
fred armisen is a genius and he used to
make the sound of um when girls are on
the toilet
tell me but but the fart that comes out
i can't do it as good as him
oh god it was it's so accurate it was
actually like yeah how are you so
accurate
where are you getting this intel i mean
fred's in a long-term relationship let's
not out that it might be natasha's
butt sound well they're not together
anymore so is that this is this was
pretty i just hang out with you just to
know who what do you want to know who
will benefit
who
you remember that aretha franklin song
[Music]
i was going to ask you speaking of fred
only if you enjoy it my favorite thing
to do is improv singing mirroring
only
it's my favorite thing ever it's my
favorite thing too i have certain things
that are my favorite things yes you
talked about
something
um when you had mature wits on yes that
uh touched um like a it was a little
flicker in me that i was like oh i
relate to that you were like that's your
fave well just when you said the thing
about like i wish i could go to a camp
and like do the thing that i do and then
come home and be a dad like yeah well
that was me on the multicam and that
yeah i understand that yeah just a
little talent show well that's you
getting called rudolph and liking it i'm
okay with liking attention yeah and if
there's a safe little corraled off space
yeah where you can go you know movie
sets are similar tv shows are similar
it's like a built-in community and
everyone's okay with you needing to
razzle dazzle yeah and what's so wrong
about that you need to razzle you want a
resident and from what i can tell the
people in the audience like watching
razzle dazzle so it's mutually
beneficial they like razzle dazzle and
they don't want to do it they don't want
to do it you do it val
uh we've gotten val out on stage which
she's helped me understand that like
i've i've always thought like everyone
in the audience was like me when i was a
little boy i would go to plays and i'd
be like they're going to call me up
were you ready i was ready
did you do shows in the living room and
stuff
yes i sang little songs improvised songs
learned very quickly if you want to be a
shiny rock yeah uh learning how to
improvise a song was like the fastest
way to like blow money it is the best
parlor trick it's the best parlor check
it's like a little david blaine you
swallow uh yes
i yes you know what i mean he lives in
your belly and if you want to be like i
saw him
the last time i saw him do something was
uh
he he produced uh frogs from his throat
but it was deeply living frogs living
frogs they were alive when they came out
yeah they came out of his throat how
long were you talking to him before the
frogs came out uh
i didn't talk to him before i was
sitting next to him uh at an audience
but okay second question and did he say
sorry i have a frog in my head
because then he chose not to no because
no one time we were that's the magic but
he did drink a lot of water before
so he's keeping them hydrated duh you
don't want to kill a frog in your throat
no because i think we have a lot of
stomach acid right yeah i'm gonna say
yeah are you you're a scientist based on
the stomach acid of cows i don't know
based on my gerd
your girdle my my my gastrointestinal
probably would well i've had no
unfortunately you'd be the first to know
i was told probably in like
2012 that i had it and kind of like
trust me
yeah yeah but i think once you have
children and your body and your organs
move you know more dribs move
wow me and your blades don't get along
all the time you're peeing currently
right now well i make people val peer
pants all the time that's that's the
best thing for a clown yeah that's
that's a true sign for a clown the clown
is like oh my god this is the do you buy
her the period underwear
she has it yeah and it hangs on the
shower yeah yeah because you hand you
hand rinse you got a hand set you got to
hand rinse that you got to get that
blood out you got to get that blood out
or that pee pee can i ask you do you
love intimacy as much as i do because i
love it you mean having sex with your
wife or just talking about omg thank you
for making it safe for me to be like
don't you just love to bone down
i mean like
i meant
i meant intimacy like the like that val
and i
are like comfortable like we're not
we're not dating anymore and the period
underwear is on the the shower because
you're a grown-ass man and that's what
it should be and also like hey and
you're raising a child like
we're humans and it's real [__] it's
real [__] dating is fake [__] dating is
fake why would you want to do that like
the people that are like perpetually
single you want to go on like a million
like so uh you have two brothers like
what is this like people that don't fart
in front of their partner that means you
can i get a trophy for you
katie is laughing because she knows i
always bring up fart policy and everyone
looks at me disgusted that i fart in
front of val
i don't understand maya don't get me
wrong
sometimes i try to be more polite to my
co-workers and like don't take it easy
no just like don't take it easy on the
rippers but what i'm saying is like how
can you not be a human with the person
that you live with i don't want someone
lying to me yeah constantly constantly
and also in pain
and pain like gurgle girl
i shouldn't i shouldn't constantly like
pull a dutch oven i should try to be
more conscientious i said this on stage
the other night and i was just being
honest that's my favorite i was just
being real and i was like i was talking
about this like there are three examples
of why i love being
married one of them just for fun is we
were talking about what our favorite
subway sandwich was remember when we all
ate at subway of course i did it my
entire groundlings career of course was
fueled by a subway sandwich that's all
you can do we all thought it was healthy
too we were like this is so healthy this
is like air one this is like
now it's like the public library i see
people in the subway and i'm like are
you okay like
i'm in the door and you're like you guys
are right
you know they have those panic buttons
you push on bridges like it's like there
is hope there should be one of those in
subway what'd you do today how do you oh
babe
i went to the subway and i freed these
three people
there should be like negotiators with
bull horns being like that is not real
ham it's not ham do you remember the
rumor when they were saying that the
tuna was made out of like something that
wasn't fish yeah you know who started
that rumor you dan quizno
i'm so sorry
all my improv instincts said i should
say yes it was me but i wanted to say
damn quizno
i wanted to apologize for a dan quiz no
joke
um where were we so oh i said what was
yours and she said we love each other
that's like foregone yeah like there's
no seduction we love each other yeah uh
and be on that foundation i felt free
she said it was a six inch meatball and
i said ooh
the hungry girl's choice and
and the punch line is my uh i went and
we had sex that night like it wasn't a
big deal like but dating you can't say
like ooh the hungry unless you're an
[__] no but when you love each other
she would like she would not order it in
front of you because she was embarrassed
that's exactly right yeah we we throw
down how do we do that well i guess we
have to sell ourselves to what will do
to be bought to be bought right like and
then this is this is cute right
but this is what i'm talking about
period underwear on the shower spigot
sure dial i'm not a jerk i don't care
whatever you want to call it pete my
it's your tell me where you get in the
shower and you turn the
turn on the faucet oh turn on the faucet
first oh it's a spigot right handle
well my my shower is old and weird it's
a spigot right well i'm picturing
you're picturing the the basement with
the bowling alley yeah exactly
you knew where the riff was i was like
there's an aesthetic
it's a locked off
it's a locked off shot like there is a
camera on it it's locked off no it's
pushing in slowly um that okay so that's
one of the threads we have don't feel
bad about talking about paul oh you
never told the story i want to tell you
the story
are you going to tell me at the end of
this if i have adhd or not because i
might cut you off too many times so just
let me know if i do
feel like a piece of pineapple in a
non-fruit salad right now or do you feel
like you're in a fruit salad because the
same thing is happening this is a this
is a new chock full fruit sauce and it's
trying to have some tropical flavor oh
my god in pomegranate and that's africa
oh give it to me and by the way have you
had a fruit salad with mint on it
because why aren't there all mint fruits
it's the best you know what i do
sometimes when i'm really feeling like i
want to have people over and feed them
mm-hmm
just a little bit of lemon not a lot and
just a little bit of honey not a lot
because why would you need fruit on here
that's crazy and mint you
win yeah you brought up farting the best
so that you have an open fart policy
then i won't forget to tell you my
pleasure i sometimes i get called out
quite a bit for like all right buddy at
work too
i mean listen at snl yeah because it's a
it's a you're there all the time well
it's a college dorm yeah and you're
there too late in the morning like and
you ate mcdonald's at six in the morning
so and the griddle's coming back
guess what the mcrib is back guys
that's a funny way to announce a
mcdonald's part hey mcrib is back good
news guys
you're blowing a huge horn you are the
first
and like a ram's horn and p
yeah
i don't like the word ashkenazi because
it has nazi in the last four letters
they weren't nice to us pete listen the
nazis they were not nice to us
to us jews where
um is your family from in lithuania
i love it so i saw that your mother is
from villainous my father your father
forgive yeah forgive and forget okay
[Laughter]
villainous fine so i'll show you i
texted my lithuanian mom uh wait is she
lithuanian
what left when she was seven no fleeing
then leave the oshka well actually the
lithuanians weren't great i've heard
during world war two i don't know i
wasn't there yeah but they weren't they
certain nobody's gonna make i don't know
i'm not gonna talk
i remember so new at learning about my
lithuanian heritage let's put it this
way my mom went to a holocaust museum
and left a little disappointed in lady
lithuania that's all i remember so i
don't know the details and maybe my mom
misread a plaque but my my friend moshe
cashier gave me [__] obviously jewish
moshe uh moses
if moshe didn't convince you casher
you're like
we get it okay that's a bit over kell
but he was joking that as soon as world
war ii i can't do this joke wait it's
[__] just like they just started
building horrible bills
that's terrible it's fine though because
you represented by saying moshe cash or
said it you didn't say that's right i
didn't say it you're just quoting you're
just quoting i was quoting i was quoting
by the way the police are here they've
come to arrest you
the pit police the bit police that is
avail val and i do that
no when we do friday when we talk i was
talking about this past friday i said
china is shaped like a witch i don't
know if you the country
like you know how italy is a boot yes uh
kentucky's a chicken leg notice the
witch
uh china is a witch flying towards
lithuania like it's flying right to left
i can't wait to check her out you gotta
check her out she's kind of hot i love
witches by the way okay we're gonna get
to that yep put a broomstick love them
we're gonna you have no idea what waters
you just waded into i was a reenactor in
salem so
but don't worry it's right you're
massachusetts modern day salem nothing
of historical airport happened i've been
i've been to all the crystal shops but
it was in denver's danvers was salem
village i've been to danvers well then
you've been to where all the real [__]
happened yeah which trial
is that mint on this yes there's mentos
on this stamp
hot danvers
hot danvers hot damn okay i said chyna
looks like a witch and then maya it
wasn't even a bit i was like i'm not
saying people from china are witches
that's how afraid
i can get sometimes i want to see this
out with bits and being pulled over for
a bit here's what's hard right now
other than me
we were hard when we were hard we were
wet
creating
creative content in the in the days of
social media
is rough
well because everything's on the record
everything is on the record i don't care
for that my instinct when twitter
started i remember was like yeah i don't
think i should do that yeah no i know
what you mean i don't want i don't want
someone to go hey remember that thing
you said 18 years ago yes um i have it
right here i just felt like that's not
for me and um
i think about it a lot in the freedom
that we had at snl when i was there
um
not to say anything about what i did or
didn't do just that like i didn't have
that hanging over my head like we had
internet trolls and that was just just
percolating yeah and that was really fun
because i love being called chipmunk
cheeks and things like that but like cc
oh yeah sure wait cmc
cmc i'm making chipmunk 2 letters but
chip monk it's
chip
chip chunk cheeks chip chip chunk cheeks
chip cheeks you found a way to make ccc
right that's because that's a really
good musical improvisation yes it's a
good parlor trick
uh so oh the trolls would call you
chipmunk cheeks yeah by the way no get
the [__] out of here get the [__] out
get the [__] out of here yeah what do
your cheeks look like yeah and we'll see
who's laughing come winter
and by the way i'm smart i store my nuts
i keep them for when it's cold outside
okay this is gonna be crazy but val and
i we laugh because every time we have
sex i'll say like i'll mean it earnestly
i'll go like what a babourino like i'll
say i know you think it's cute wait
during or after like right before oh
like kind of when she's nice becoming
nude you're not sick of this right
she hasn't heard that one have you
baberino that's fresh i'm cooking it
fresh fruit are you really yes you're
trying to find the fresh putting it in
the grid on the griddle on the griddle
yeah the grip
i'm putting it in the subway bridge
remember when subway used to cut the top
out and then put that removed bread on
top give it to me
give it to me you know why because i
like that inner soft bread yeah the
energy does do you like the crust or the
soft when you get a roll at a dinner
restaurant do you like like are you
cause i have weird family members who
will like they'll take the hot hot bread
and they'll like take off the crust and
hand it to the person and the family
likes the crust because they like the
inside
uh i will do both because i'm not i'm
not a child not to put down that friend
or family no he's my uncle what's his
name doug rudolph doug come on what
maybe he's having dental problems he
likes no he like no he's very particular
doug's dental health he's his dental i'm
sorry you know
i'm his dentist my uncle doug is
maybe doug rudolph he might be one of
the most fascinating human beings alive
give me one um the way he eats is like
nothing i've ever seen in my life and
it's very like he's really serious about
it and he watches it he knows he's made
fun of by everyone in our family what
does he do and he doesn't give a [__] he
gives a zero he
he loves food and he's particular about
it and he likes it the way he likes it
so i'm thinking
like um because he's been in the rest
he's in the restaurant business by the
way so he's serious about it like he
wants it to be cooked right he wants it
to taste good he wants it to be hot when
it's supposed to be hot cold when it's
supposed to be cold but like eating hard
when it's supposed to be hard when it's
supposed to be hard hey nice comeback
i'm here i'm here i'm here i don't know
because of the because i had covered but
he's brain fog he'll take um a bite of
his burger and then the knife goes with
a little bit of ketchup
and a little bit of oh man
little thing each bite has to be right
i don't hate it
audrey martin has a bit about how when
you eat a salad you make a mini salad on
every fork oh that's cute he's so
[__] clever yeah i think i'm a genius
because i because i don't do stand up
which you probably noticed
and um
i mean like because of right now because
well no just because i've never done it
in your stand up so like it's clear like
i do i do not do it even though i think
that people who are probably not
listening to your podcast or else
they'll because people that are stupid
is what i'm trying to dum-dums dum-dums
think that comedians all do stand-up yes
and there are many forms of of comedian
and i um i don't do stand-up yeah
although i will say now that i'm older
more appealing more appealing because
it's you can monologue you can whatever
is going on in you i just feel more
comfortable it's similar to what you
said on the mitch podcast
about how you were saying the first 10
years you're like work on the write the
jokes write the jokes maybe 10 years
later you can just you can just do the
feeling you know you're gonna know what
you're going to talk about well that's
true because i did a show last night and
that subway thing that i reheated for us
here just kind of came out but it wasn't
written down anywhere right and you
could do that you can rely on that and
you know you've heard of me boys yeah
yeah yeah that's a big part for me i
just wouldn't want you it's almost like
a risk maybe you've heard me say like
improvisers are like the elves and uh
stand-ups are like dwarves i actually
kind of mean that to put down my own
species even though i improvised as well
but like i am a stand-up yeah and we're
like alone and we go into the minds of
maurya
what's that your dobby dobby from from
harry potter oh i'm sorry lord of the
rings are bust but yeah
i understand now that i am dobby thank
you
dobby is pretty cute my manager looks
exactly like ron weasley
oh you're into it i am we were hard when
we were hard really yeah
ron weasley's cute the redhead yeah i
wish i wasn't so aghast because maybe
he's a fan and he's like oh blow you out
he's adorable i'm good-looking he well
he is meant to be a little bit of a goof
but he grows he grows into it he does
but he has those two brothers they're a
little more
waka-waka they're both fozzie bear both
of his brothers are fozzie because i got
two fozzies sorry i just want to do the
voice please keep going okay listen
we're does pta fart
well i'm not gonna out him on your
podcast why not you have to let him come
okay yeah any time been a dream guest
for a long time but listen uh you know
what val and i were talking i guarantee
if you have him coming i'll answer you
well
that well then we won't embarrass pt but
i was talking to val this is too
embarrassing
you don't have to wait it's your podcast
i know but if we're not telling secrets
who cares it's sort of well i just you
know what i feel i feel badly if i like
open the fart gates for someone else
yeah spread and release
remember the breathe right were you on
was that your season it was keenan and
and they put a breathe right strip
between your butt cheeks so i remember
yeah i think you were on at that point i
don't remember anything pete why would
you no i mean i really don't remember
most things well we said that on the way
in that we're not good with time i'm not
good with time and i think i black out
time
yeah a little bit i don't mean blackout
like blackout drunk like i think i
delete it i think i have some some
blocks i think
whether or not others professionals
might call it 80d i think there's
something that helps us meaning we like
the way our brains work yes correct me
if i'm wrong yeah speak for myself i
like the way my brain works yeah but i
do tend the bridge is on fire behind me
yes so i'm really just kind of doing
what i'm doing yeah like when we're
trying to think of other guests that
i've had on that i'm like don't talk
about i couldn't think of any do you
think that
is it it just has that change since
parenthood for you because it has for me
meaning it's worse well it just speaks i
think that it's just because you have to
be more present you have to be present
constantly the secret right and i don't
mean oprah's like think about it and
you'll be honest and i'll go
tiara
tiara this louis
my neck isn't moving that much and then
it just cracked i was trying to do like
the like and it just like i'm so stiff
i need i i want to i want to be an adult
where i get massages
every day or even once a week
i heard edie falc
oh give it to me uh she was on npr or
something and she was and this is before
i had leela
which of course i don't have to say this
but i like saying it greatest joy in my
life
i mean best thing in the damn world i
wish
there were nine of them i mean i love
her so much possible i mean let's get
mormon with it um getting mormon with it
getting mormon with it
that's a song right
since the slap i had to reference
weren't you there for the slapping you
must have been do you want to know the
truth hit it i was at the bar
funny
you're gonna say
paul's category had paula just lost
and by the way
get the [__] [__] out of here academy
right at a screening where he gave a
little chitty chat at the village we
were yeah and we were sitting in front
of whatever the sisters are called there
so
the heim sisters yes forgive and forget
so the other heim sisters are behind me
and pta was going on and on about how
amazing what is the one in the movie
forgive alana forgive it forget it's
just names it's not personal i i think
she's transcendent and amazing i don't
make people apologize anymore for [__]
unless they're [__] because we all
are busy and we have lies that's what i
mean
pre-kid i'd be like alana heim but now
i'm like the wonderful woman from that
movie we're grown-ups yes we're
grown-ups we're farting what i was going
to say was i was talking to val in
mid-conversation i spread and let it out
so it was soundless and we just kept
talking that's that's intimacy that's
absolutely something that i do thank you
and i feel so safe very helpful
because
exactly and like i feel like that's more
offensive you don't want to be like
because that would almost almost like
punctuate like the the it's an ellipses
it does punctuate it it's an elliptical
technically it's an ellipses i've had a
semicolon come out of my
my semiconductor
and an exclamation point is when there's
a little [__] at the end it's like
little [__]
my dot my my smallest dog does that
sometimes she'll she'll poop but then
she doesn't like she just runs off she
doesn't finish and then she'll just run
i'm like what is that why is there a
tiny poop on the floor love needs she
just left it there that's what brody
brody will walk for a while there's
always the poop and then there's the
it's like i'm like a forensic scientist
like in a plane crash i'm like well this
is the point of impact but this this
residue here says that the dog walked
because like because don't you hate it
when they scoot they're they scoot their
butts i heard everything about my dog
[__] uh it's not for me it's a
bummer well
i'm sorry who likes it i think some dog
people are like i love the bags i love
the squish
they're like they're like
they're into it he just moved so often i
didn't know how much of it it's my first
dog i didn't know how much of it was
going to be your first dog
and they and they poop in boxes i don't
have cats because i'm allergic so i'm
allergic to i don't want to offend you
because you love you you love cats but i
always thought cats were [__] but
they are that's their charm yeah a dog
likes you who [__] cares i used to
have a joke he'd like um a pillow with
my t-shirt on it yeah he'd be like i
love your dad like who cares if you get
a cat
to love you
that's like shocking it's as a performer
i enjoy it it's like a bad audience yeah
and you won them over now they're
purging they like me and they make a
pleasure sound dogs don't have a
pleasure sound there's no
it's just
i'm not sure what that sounded i loved
it and i needed it where were we i was
about to tell oh so do i have i'm in
front of you no but it's my job it's
also
it's also undiagnosed because i was born
in 1972. so who knows what else i have i
mean i'm sure
we all have it
definitely i mean yes i mean by now
you'd think it's a hard yes
um it's a hard yes when it's so hard yes
oh
so i wasn't sitting in front of the
heims and their father who's great in
that movie and paul kept going on about
how great alana is and i i i could have
been projecting it but i was like this
is getting uncomfortable because the
other ones were behind me oh no and i
was just and he was just like and i mean
look at her she's just i don't mean look
at her like her beauty but she is but he
was just like she's my muse she i made
the movie for her and i'm like
do you do you do that thing that i do
wherever you want everybody to be happy
yes i'm a i'm a people pleaser
please yeah it can be a pee pee problem
by the way yeah that's correct and i had
to learn later in life how to have pp
boundaries yeah do you have pvp you seem
like you happy boundaries yeah i do i
was intimidated emailing you i was like
she really seems like strong really yeah
no that's a lot go back and reread the
emails and imagine me being like oh miss
rudolph like just like like those were
why do you think that because of like
characters i played or something cause
people say that you just seem like a
very because i have like dark hair yes
i i think there's a concept of
confidence in your work there's a
confidence right now that i'm just like
this person is selfish right now oh yeah
oh come on get this woman a havana
a family
where's my still sorry i'm gonna get
where's the jar don't worry about it
we'll use that shot we won't even show
what you were doing and i'll be like
these are all flaps these are high these
are high yes you're low and so am i
you're good i'm good
okay get the jar of pipes from
twbb
uh do you call it twbb in the in the
house only only in the house sweetheart
sweetheart this is not t.w.b twbp is on
okay
where were we
it doesn't matter here's my pta story oh
yes please i'm at lady largo i didn't
know what paul looked like
i got off stage now i do he's a real
baby you know he's a [__] dope ass
babe reno and we were talking about this
off cam
i think he's only i think he's 10 times
the babe i watched the making of
magnolia featured and i was like look no
offense he was a babe then too but i was
like he's skinny he looks young i
watched that too and i was like [__]
he's pretty hot well i mean i hope so i
mean but that was that because i was
doing research on him because we didn't
have like the the googling that we have
now at the time that i met him oh my god
so when magnolia came out you couldn't
just go on youtube and go making of
magnolia but now you can it's awesome
yeah you can also there's so many
there's so many more useful things for
this bank bank now yeah if you want to
spank it to your own husband which by
the way
i wish there were interviews
val i masturbate over my own life
i don't i think i know what he's saying
he masturbates to all of there will be
blood
twenty twenty four well i come when the
oil shoots out so before i come a pipe
goes
when people run and i've deafened a
child with mine okay so wonderful no
that's so wonderful the only way to stop
me from [__] is he goes
and they blow it up with barrels of dino
mite otherwise i'll just stop just for
days oh my god i'm so sorry so anyway i
come off stage and there's p paul tom
paul tell me
paul thomas
i've never thought or heard full time
and it's too late now because i am gonna
use it yeah yeah there's paul tom and i
and then planning
oh the best
oh planning um flanny goes
this is this is paul and he knows that i
love
we're not going to get into it he knows
he's my favorite he knows all of our
loves and wishes and secret desires well
we've talked yeah flanny knows all and
if you want something on the streets as
i said in the 70s oh that's solid
it's the best
telephone teleflanigan
dial a flanagan i don't know what i mean
by that
but i told him he knows about my love of
pta and he goes there's a paul and i'm
like you know it's just some guy named
paul so i go [__] off you shouldn't be
backstage no i didn't say that i go next
it really seems like you
i go nice to meet you and he goes i
think flanny just went is paul thomas
anderson and i go oh my god and then i
proceed to tell
paul tom
i go has we talked for a minute and then
i go are you aware of the theory in the
master my favorite movie tied for first
is the twbb and the master tied for
first number three
uh phantom thread uh get real so i mean
he's all three
so
i go
are you aware of the theory
that joaquin is the id
phil is the ego and amy adams is the
superego
paul tom then proceeds to tell me that
what you probably already know about
paul tom is that he doesn't really think
that way he's heard that theory
if you look at the poster it's a it's a
rorschach test with the three characters
and i'm just like
it really opened up the movie for me the
first time i saw it i was a little
confused
i know there's a rorschach on the poster
i remember that i i sure wasn't pete
explaining it too i was like that sort
of supports the theory that this is a
psychological analysis of wow so that's
what i was looking for wow you just gave
me what i was looking for
and he was like uh i've heard that
theory but i don't really work that way
and i was like yeah but you know like
uh
joaquin jerks off on the beach
i know and then phil gets a hand job
from his super ego so he can only come
when his super ego tells him it's okay
whoa right but that's a lot of thinking
can jerk on the beach yeah
this is what i think paul tom thought
too because he's like well when we shot
that he was like joaquin was just
improvising and i proceeded to say what
like i don't believe him
i'm like what it's mirrored in the movie
perfectly you get a little bit mad not
mad but
like probably loud and loud
and i was like
he's like yeah joaquin was just doing
his thing and we were following him and
i'm like but if you look at i said this
i was like that shot of him jerking off
is framed perfectly so you can't see his
ding-a-ling i'm sure he was just going
like this but his shot so you it looks
like he's drinking out i was like how do
you you need time to frame that up and
how long was he doing it so i'm getting
worked up and and i'm like
not you went full throttle instantly you
like jumped right in well i'm getting
louder for fun i know i'm sure i was
being cool as a cute no you weren't in
the sun you got really french and you
had a cigarette immediately
and he goes i'm telling him about the
mirroring jerk-offs and he goes
you know i've seen the film
that's [__] funny paul tom
and i went he's a funny guy i went home
and i was like i'm not i wasn't really
worried about it but i was aware that i
had i was in the neighborhood of i blew
it oh
so you're ready for my winking story
then
i got to meet joni mitchell tell me
journey i got to meet can i do i got to
meet joan she goes by joan by the way
i'm doing alan rickman in love actually
journey mitchell i don't even do you
know what i'm talking about
no
do you want do you want another truth
i've seen some of love actually
just the porn ones just the punches i've
seen i've only seen
well there's a porn story in love
actually that's actually quite jarring
it's martin freeman
and i've definitely not seen that part
you need to watch it why really you said
you love christmas oh i do
love actually really
yeah what are you doing
i've seen is is there one of the crazy
is the soccer girl in this in the chanel
ads in it is that the same movie emma
thompson
kieran knightley keira knightley chanel
girl chanel girl from the soccer movie
okay she's in it right here at choppers
nightly cure choppers nightly i've seen
that part
okay well you need to give it i think
i've like seen it at like like somebody
like watching over someone's shoulder on
a plane or like it was already on on tv
i understand this is how i am with the
godfather don't tell paul tom
i
is it an age thing maybe am i am i
significantly older than you like what
year did it come out i think we're
similar in i'm gonna turn 50 in july
okay you're seven years older than i am
but that's bye
bye so when i was a senior you were a
fresh man wait that's no you might not
have even started
no you weren't you're you're you're
you're you're in yours is all of high
school and then
i'm smart then three years
wait wait seven so when i was in sixth
grade you were graduating high school
yeah yeah i know so i was a year off
okay
that's also not oh did your school go to
fifth grade
or did it go to six
mine went from seventh to twelfth
oh
canada no here oh canada i just didn't
realize i made a joke
i went k to eight you went and then i
went nine to twelve
that's not what i did we're good i did i
did k to 6
7 to 12. okay we're gonna do the winking
oh [__] right sorry
winking somebody also told me a paul
thomas anderson story where they were
yelling about how boogie nights didn't
work and then they realized after the
fact that it was they were yelling at
paul thomas anderson why were they
yelling about it in the first place
i don't know i think he was on cocaine
and he said he was in a circle and it
was steve martin my friend
and uh who that he didn't know was paul
tom wait who was your friend that was on
cocaine i don't know if i want to out
him i'll tell you this is a real this
was a yeah this was a person that you
know that did that and he's now an actor
and i wonder and he's in a movie that i
know
it's a scorsese movie that i know paul
thomas
i wonder if he ever watches he goes
that's the guy robert de niro was the
one who was cooked up and yeah and joe
pesci yeah oh my god
robert de niro snorted joe pesci
that's a short joke joe pesci hasn't
heard yet oh i'm sorry
another
robert de niro snorted me joke great
that was my joe pesci i i've never tried
it and that was the first time it felt
good oh i see i felt comfortable because
you were doing it that's the whole show
maya
that's the whole show why aren't you a
therapist you make people so comfortable
that's
you listen to mitch see if you're ready
to
then wheel there are some where they're
like i resist this
some people do well to be fair i think
because my inn to you was one miss annie
woods who
i mean she's a legend to me yeah she's
alive she's a legend as a of a human
being so like if if you love annie woods
you're you're in for me yeah annie's
wonderful and we this is my talk show
the background for my talk show she did
the wardrobe for that that's how we met
and that's that was a long time ago i
thought you meant the couch no no the
couch was the wardrobe for your talk yes
and had it dusted for you thank you was
keep it crispy on your talk show too no
that's on the pod you'll say that at the
end in fact technically because you said
it we have to end
oh no hundred percent jkers oh phew 100
yeah no no no what if you kicked me out
i never would and i couldn't because
you're so confident question mark why do
you think i'm confident
i think maybe it might be because
well first of all what what the f is
going on here what the f
what we do we're syndicated in utah
second mormon burn sorry my latter-day
saints
anyone that can dominate on
saturday night live
that's the name of the show right
i hope so
i've been calling it saturday night
anyone that can like that's what it was
called originally no sketch is
and consistently
and live
you gotta right you got a little it's
the way i feel about stand-ups as well
it's that um
confidence thing that which is which is
interesting because it's the same thing
this is like well i can't do that but i
i only recently i mean i'm 49 years old
and i only recently discovered that i'm
a live performer like i actually thought
that i was an a yeah i thought i was an
actor um meaning like i do it all but
like i'm better at live performance
that's what i that's where i shine yes
internally that's where i feel good and
where i feel like myself and your brain
probably comes my brain [__] fires on
all cylinders see that's the way it
could have gone that's the match point
yeah allen's your favorite filmmaker and
um but it is it's like the ball could
have gone this way that way so some
people
there i remember reading about this in
psychology in like high school they were
like it's a real thing basketball
players in front of a crowd are better
than basketball players non-friend of
crowd absolutely i think that's me i am
give me a crowd
or give me death yeah yeah that's what
old hemingway said he said that yeah and
i i and i felt good like oh it took me
all this time to learn to to to admit
that about myself or to even notice that
about myself i should say because
i don't know i never noticed it before i
just felt like
well i probably know why because i've
always thought that i had to do what
people do like i never felt like the
real thing even though really truly i
was just making my own path but i didn't
know that i was like i'm weird i'd
better do what everybody else is doing
so i try i always tr have tried to do
the things you're supposed to do i'm
supposed to
act in movies i'm supposed to
do the things that actors do but
but i'm far more alive performing live
not to say that i'm like
always happy with it that's a whole
other conversation yeah it's just that
that's the place where i feel like oh
now i know what i'm doing i totally get
it it's it's um the feedback of it it
gives it life sometimes doing it in
front of a camera i constantly have to
remind myself
uh people will see this
i know
like people will see this at some point
this will delight them how different was
it for you with the multicam versus well
we had a little audience but they were
they were sort of a pretend and they
were like this
they laughed
they laughed when they heard the line
that was the laugh because they had
watched it
in blocking i i realized lately
that they had already seen it in
blocking and most of them were on their
phones and it's because they were there
for 22 hours and that's okay and to be
fair
studio audiences in los angeles
are probably um you know working actors
as well yes so it's just not the same
it's not great no and i would improvise
and they would never laugh and i would
and god doesn't feel great
yeah it hurt my feelings because i was
like if this was because i've been
pre-co when it was a real audience like
300 people you'd improvise if you said
like hello instead of hey people would
laugh just because it was different and
i was like here i am on a multicam so
i'm going to say some like take a big
swing yeah nothing and you're like
that's so disappointing i would get a
little upset about that oh i would i
would have such hurt feelings yeah i
would get hurt absolutely um so you're a
live performer here's a question um on
snl this is one of the things that i'm
like
so take an impression and you do lots of
wonderful impressions
thanks
i've seen your flanny
friend dan van kirk taught me that
that's so accurate it's not down here
it's up it's up here well he's a barrel
chested
belfastian he is he's the you know he
does this best belfast intermittent
belfast
jesus christ i'm so sorry
when the pressure's on
performing yes doing stand-up yes doing
a voice doing an impression yes harder
under pressure i find for sure i i did
never i don't feel like i've ever really
learned how to be an impressionist
because
i think either i think impressionists
are either impressionists or they're not
but
i feel like
because i i think more because i i think
i
do impressions with more with like um
it's because i have a musical ear i
think i like pick up the pitch i pick up
their sounds and their the way they talk
but when the pressure's on you could
still find that pitch sometimes not yeah
sometimes not good we just did it
because we have a clip actually you
couldn't quite find it here
oh yeah
yeah i see i'm just kidding 100 for real
last
day before yesterday saturday my buddy
natasha leon hosted and she just broke
up with fred right yeah
i tried to tell you
i tried to tell you it's a callback like
a year ago a year ago forgive and forget
maybe two
we don't know natasha's one of those
people by the way when you meet her
you're like is this a is this a bit she
was like oh geez yeah i'm down in
brooklyn and i'm going over there see
you're doing it i give myself a pack of
cigarettes
what the [__] i care that's
now that was it that was good right
but then it was like my idea to say
let's do impressions of you we did them
and mine wasn't as good fred's was
perfect of her yes to her you just did
it
but that's it but i didn't do it the way
i the way i normally do it i did it on
stage the other day i was trying to do
john c reilly this is at the largo oh oh
i'm gonna buy the lakers but it's not
quite right it's not i can hear it it's
not quite right it's just so something
i'm planning on just like well you were
relaxed i was gonna say just relax and
think about benefit think about like
record record ralph z that's better it
was better
i asked him for the lightest champagne
they had
i feel like you're john c
sounds like a cartoon dog john c which i
like a lot i hear that and i took it as
a harsh criticism no it's wonderful
he's so lovable i asked him to come on
this podcast many times and he's always
been like
no nobody wants to hear what i mean
you know what you should do then you
should make a clay model of him and just
do that voice the whole time and it cuts
to just a still shot of him being like
well
it's not good that's by the way that was
not good
i don't know that i can do john's voice
we used to do um phil too talk about
we're going through the pta frames it
was just
you have a wife oh that's so good
actually it's mission impossible three
yeah but i actually felt that in my body
a little bit isn't that great that gave
me a little like
yeah yeah yeah that's that's the that's
the parlor trick
i'm so touched that you liked it it came
out well and it's mission impossible
three phil ah it was very good
i'm gonna kill her oh wow that's very
good
high five i got it again
and my kneecraft i got it again that was
very good very happy about this what's
what i feel like i need to make you
shine what was the one you wanted oh no
no honey honey
baby i'm feeling great don't worry about
me shining okay but i and i'll shine
later don't worry yeah it'll come out
naturally you're shining
um tell me about the wink about the wink
johnny joni mitchell oh yeah that's how
he got on this journey
it is now my duty to go home and watch
love actually yeah um i'll put it in my
spank bank so i
was um
jody mitchell recorded um a lot of her
incredible um albums at uh a then a m
records which is now henson studios not
too far from here yeah it's not far from
hollywood california if you pass the
kermit you've passed it
that's what i say about a lot of things
in life like when my kids are really
over doing i'm like past you're about to
pass the kermit yes it's like jump the
shark oh my god sweetheart you're this
close
to passing the kermit
and there's no going back to henson
studios once you pass the kermit all
right you love don't you love seeing
that kermit i do showbiz don't you love
showbiz yeah and i will tell you this
growing up in this city because i grew
up in los angeles
there were a lot more things like that
around the city that that are gone that
i miss like there was an incredibly
large
uh chocolate chip cookie spinning on a
finger like a basketball in front of the
famous amos cookie shop on sunset i
think it was either hollywood or sunset
just a big cookie famous famous cookies
but he'd spin it on his finger like a
like a basketball here's a question yeah
nuts or no nuts
i thought you were gonna ask me a cookie
question
oh i know yeah i know
i know
it just made me so happy
that you took a stab nuts or no nuts
i will ask you a cookie question no
um crispy or cakey
yeah i know crispy what do you think i
am an [__]
keep it crispy that's not what it means
but yeah but um how do you like what
about pancakes i i like a pancake i
enjoy pancakes what do i want in it
well before we get to what's in it
like thin like swedish thin or fluffy
i'm gonna eat a fluffy before i'm gonna
eat it then you like you like them she's
gone she's gone you like a crepe not a
not a crepe not a clip because i was
picking up okay well yes but swedish
pancakes you can get the mix of gilsons
mexico you can get the mix at the
mexicalsons no the mexicans where do you
want that salsa
no
you can get swedish pancake mix okay
it's very sour
sour dough i like that while we're
lithuay
hey hey that's the look away we lit the
way
snoop dogg yeah he's also lithuanian i
knew it
i wish there was i knew there was a joke
a perfect joke right there something
like a weed pun
but i couldn't do it snoop is the best
i'll always love snoop because i brought
my grandmother um my jewish grandmother
to snl when he hosted and i introduced
her to snoop dogg and he said
damn you're looking good mama
to my now deceased wonderful uh
um
dead right there immediately yeah just
dead dead it was death
also she was so beautiful and so hot
that he was right
like he has good taste yeah yeah he has
great taste in grandmothers that was
dean dean edwards who was on snl briefly
used to do denzel washington and it was
always complimenting someone's
girlfriend and i still think about it
all the time he'd go that's you that's
you all right that's you oh my god that
was so funny yeah dean that's dean
edward i mean like he found that
i love i love a very particular
impression that's all you need that's
that's why when i did phil you go to you
need the touchstone right
okay you were saying joni mitchell joni
mitchell jeremy mitchell she came back
to
every time she came back to which is now
henson studios oh the cookie here's my
question yeah oh yeah is that cookie in
storage somewhere it's a filmmaker
question because here's old uh q
tarantino sure doing once upon a time in
h wood did he put it up there and he
brings out back all that hollywood stuff
i bet it was post
well what year was that supposed to be
it was 70s right the 70s there was a lot
of neon in that movie that doesn't exist
anymore i'm pretty sure yeah so i wonder
if in a showbiz town like this the
spinning cookie is colin
just go where's the cookie
hey tarantino
where's the cookie he's like they're
calling again he's like oh those [__]
cookies
the cookie's not in the movie but some
of that neon so what i'm saying is
somebody who wants to shoot that cookie
do you think it's not alive is that what
you're saying the cookie's not no longer
alive no the cookie is alive how do you
know i thought you said the cookie's not
there anymore it's not there anymore so
it's in storage is what i'm saying and
then you think but i'm worried that in
storage it's not alive you think someone
preserved the cookie yeah i hope so it's
not a real well i think famous amos
lives in maui now right next to paul
quizno
that's a
40 minute call back and i'm feeling
pretty good all right so joni mitchell i
couldn't love a clunky lazy um
fake name more oh my god oh it's my
favorite phil canoe
when i write a script i'll just put in
horrible fake names do you really
why
waste your time you know you're going to
be mine
why why
waste time going like
wasting time you just put it in phil
canoe
yeah but then like so much time can be
wasted extra joke you get to giggle for
extra well if it's a comedy you can call
him phil canoe oh what you're saying is
if you're trying to have it be a real
person you write a lot of dramas is what
you're saying i write a lot of drama d
trump
drama that gets graded as a d is what i
know it's like a d d minor oh no okay so
joni mitch
which also involves a cookie the store
involves a cookie a crispy cookie with
toffee you ever have toffee or something
salty in a cookie i love toffee
dead
dead serious dead serious
the most serious i've seen you a point
in the face fell to neutral intense
neutral
so not neutral
i love toffee
it was like don't talk about my kids
i just had i just recently for the first
time had matzo with toffee on it
it was delightful wow you're weeping uh
that's saying a lot for me you really
got me in my element i was serious and i
didn't even notice i loved it and i
needed it well that's it
i love i love being seen i love seeing
keep going we were hard when johnny
mitchell came to henson studios
and i happened to be singing there that
day with my good friend on a gas tire
and um
so many wonderful people
that i know and love and musicians i
know and love were there that day and
a wonderful dear friend of mine named
wendy melvoy who is a wonderful musician
who played with prince for many many
years
said come down joni's here
she's reclaiming her
her youth or i think she said that her
past she said she's reclaiming her past
coming to come into a [__] room and
joanie mitchell sitting there she had a
beautiful beret on
her hair was braided loosely it's
stunning this woman is joni mitchell
stunning she's stunning
long red nails
beautiful ring that's uh um somebody
made for her
some [__] great person made for just
all of it's perfect yeah yeah
people are coming to pay their respects
hello johnny all these princess diana
was there
wow
i mean they just won the long long time
ago real time yes and of all time
i was trying to think of who funny would
have been right
yeah um death by yes
where your career ends that's how she
died
princess died no me oh my god yes and
i'm worried about getting canceled for a
yes hand because when my guest makes a
joke i i can't leave them because my
people pleasers and i've said in my mind
your honor it was a yes and you are ppp
your people pleaser pete
petey oh did people call you petey only
the best ones
oh we fade to black
the episode ends
everybody learns something
what's funny about this story is that
like
it sounds like i'm bragging and i never
got to the good part of the story here's
the good part
oh you mean without the good part it
just doesn't just use this part
so i i got to meet joni mitchell once
and i was to reset the story
i was sorry
here's what i like to do i don't like to
make people uncomfortable by telling
them how much i love them because i
worry that that's going to make them
feel weird or uncomfortable so i try to
play it cool which is probably why you
think i'm being cool because maybe i am
trying to play a little cool just like
i'm not going to be like i [__] love
you right so i didn't do that to joni i
just said it's so nice to meet you and i
was very warm because i wanted to
radiate love towards her because i love
her so much
and she doesn't need to know the
intricacies of why she's she's done
things for my life she wants to hear
that
maybe when we're having dinner at her
house or something you know which i've
never been interested in hang three
thank you but like she does not joni
doesn't have time for
my stories and it is
it is sort of making it about you that's
the risk don't want to do that that's
the rest so you don't want to be like
it's the year the ego and the super ego
not the first time you make not the
first time we meet i don't i don't want
to pete holmes
as it's known in your house
that i think i'm too quiet probably
and then um we're all hanging out and i
don't want to stay too long because
that's another thing where i'm like i
never want to stay too long and i always
understand i mean it's all a mess i i'm
i'm so polite that people are like she
hated me or something
so i have to i have to go back to record
with my dear friend anna and i said
i have to go i said it was so wonderful
to meet you and then i went like this
i'll see you around
and i winked at her why'd i do that
see you around
and she just went
didn't say a word just stared at me
and um someone had made cookies and i
said
you gonna eat that cookie she goes
no
is it and that was it so it was a wink
and then the cookie and then the awkward
cookie and
no and then i just left
i think it didn't go great
i'm gonna say i'm gonna make a ruling
here like a mafioso i'm listening uh
because of your comedy
right
pete she had no idea who i was no no no
no i'm disagreeing
pete she had no idea who i was she's on
tick tock pete even if she did know who
i was she did not watch anything i've
ever done because she's johnny
do you [__] rachel she's so
[__] cool
jesus she's so cool she doesn't need to
watch
mitchell flying around doing her little
ditties and nightclubs i'm under telling
her you think she's on a plane in the in
the late early 2000s flipping through a
dvd book in her fancy jet
and sees the pink bridesmaids disc and
goes oh that's that film everyone's
talking about
and i love chris o'dowd and i'd love to
just whack off
so down right now i've heard she loves
to whack off to christmas she loved joni
mitchell yeah it's called pulling a
mitchell when you whack off to that on a
private plane on a private plane and
that's what the curtain is for you go
i'm going to have my oh dowd now oh
there she goes you want to see me
mitchell my oh dowd face yeah he's
probably said that which makes me
disturbed let's see it what's your oh
dowd face my real one do you have one
but like oh face or my oh dowd face oh
dowd face
yeah that's it
that was all you needed to do
what was that
there's no
[__] way joanie mitchell i wish we
could call her
hasn't seen bridesmaids hollering she
had seen him then called joni tarantino
i've had tarantino on the hook for 10
years this publicist ducks me like covet
have you been trying you've been trying
to get him on the on the pod i mean
don't tell him he's my number two
favorite filmmaker
when he's sitting here just told
everyone
i refuse to be the person that tells him
but i've heard qut talk about how he and
pt
are sort of competent like when he saw
him and paul thompson twbb
that's paul trump that's what yeah we
gotta
none of this is usable
it's all dead audio at this point no i
don't think they can hear because the
mics are so close to our fossas
these are great
that's the that's the gift for doing the
show
are you miking your heartbeat
yeah i was trying to steal it
by putting it in my blouse it's a great
seinfeld bit from the 90s
you go to a bad motel the the tv is
always bolted to the wall he's like is
this a big problem i'd like to check out
please
i just love a physical punchline i'd
like to check out and he does it quiet
i'd like to check out please oh god
that's so is that fun
i thought i was a genius because
i started saying this before and i got
sidetracked because of my adhd we're in
the middle of a side track
we're
this is the only thing i i didn't i
tried not to think about what we were
going to talk about but i knew this was
going to happen just
constantly cutting you off and starting
new stories you think you're cutting me
off yeah
read the comments i think they're there
i think the comments are actually below
us i thought i thought for sure and i i
was this is at some point in my 20 20s
my not my 20s my 20s my 20s and my 20s
um
that
being a stand-up comedian sorry i'm
shedding it's from the cocoa there's my
hair if you need to i think that's from
me i do
you lost a little i think i'm shedding
more than normal i wear a merkin now
sounds
oh it's all there
it's like the 70s down there um your
your bush
my my bush is hanging low
it's got skalactite
pure thatch
no it's not it's not you don't have to
you know what i'm going to leave it a
mystery yeah i want people to to think
they know yeah they don't know yeah yeah
and they also don't care because joanie
doesn't care joanie's are long braided
and her vagina wears a beret
from both sides and then down so
i thought i was a genius
in that i invented two things my life
once when i was a kid i was remember i
was in the bathtub and i thought god we
should invent telephones that are
screens so that people can see them we
can see and talk to each other there you
go i got it from the jetsons i didn't
notice that i got it from the jetsons
though you know what i mean that's fine
but i invented facetime
um
and you just admitted you didn't but
you're like i totally did yeah yeah and
then um
in my 20s
because i i think stand-ups are some of
the most brilliant human beings alive
some of not all
why why was that part
to you and i said to myself
god
what is it what what is it and i said oh
being a stand-up is making witty
observations
and i thought that i thought
wait when was this maybe in my 20s and i
was like that's it
stand ups make
witty observations no i just called mike
berbiglia first of all that's adorable
and i wish i could bronze that thought
witty observations also i still don't
know how to do it but i'm i'm in awe of
it well there's actually a part of me
that wouldn't want i think it's e
cummings
i'm sorry i'm smoking a pipe
that said don't dissect the goose if you
want the song or something like that
like don't so there's part of me that
you're so free
and you can see it in your acting as
well that you're you're holding loosely
you're moving like this and it makes you
very funny and dynamic and stand-up is a
risky pursuit because you're taking this
fluid
your comedy yes that the comedy we were
when we were 10. yes it's childlike and
barefoot and we're running up the
neighbor's pool
and then you take that and you start
like kind of dissecting it and building
it and then recreating it so there's a
real risk there's almost a part of me
that wants to go don't
do like do maybe you tell a story or
improvise or whatever but i don't know i
think that's inspiring
my name is maya rudolph uh feel free to
make uh the red-nosed reindeer joke like
i don't want to see that
when you do i don't want to see that
but when you do
you're going to love it omg is this
here's what you do
where are you to do a show at logo in
conversation
that's like this people would love that
oh my god like it's really profound
but it's better mm-hmm
there's certain people i don't like um
oh there's a number a number of names
john wayne john wayne dolly parton dolly
parton they're together
it's so our sorbet and lonnie but bert's
not here and ben affleck
ben who benefit
benefit affleck it sounded like you said
owl fleck the owl theory from the
staircase
do you think it was an owl what do you
think michael peterson killed kathleen
peterson don't tell me you haven't seen
the staircase i haven't seen the
staircase the documentary i don't like
things that make me scared
well yeah stay away yeah i have a
problem with that it'll make you yeah i
have a real like i'm i'm a real i'm i'm
a real wimp with scary stuff really yes
but i love
halloween
i love witches i love quaint talent well
you love witches we didn't get to that
that was one of our threads i love them
why do you love well i just like female
empowerment
do you mean real witches or do you mean
like cartoons i'm not talking salem i'll
be honest with you i'm talking like
witchy poo
yeah yeah i want to be a witch when i'm
older i'm a little bit of a witch i got
hairy moles
i like it i like i like the kind of
weird dresses they wear it's cute i
think you would like witch history then
because they were older single powerful
women 100
that like owned land yes and then
everyone was like well the devil must
have given you that lease i mean let's
be honest everybody knows by now what
was really going on that was some
[__]
possibly with some fermented rye that
made people hallucinate oh that's my
favorite theory oh that's wonderful yeah
that's a good one i
know and don't get me wrong i'm not
special by saying this about myself i
[__] love magic i'm not talking about
going to the magic castle or anything
like that but like the idea of like the
prospect of something magical usually in
like when i'm in something that's being
created of like i just like a little
little
little a little
song
from the unexpected
like david blaine i like it
i don't like a lot of david blaine's
like body stuff it bumps i get a little
freaked out yeah that's what he's going
for
it's not for me it's not abracadabra no
ma'am it's more like
am i okay it's like i just i just sliced
myself open yeah there's like if it
involves blood i'm gonna take a pass we
were once at the juice place in our
neighborhood and there were three buff
magicians doing card tricks for us and
afterwards i said
wow i can't believe we just met david
blaine
and it was david blaine and val was like
that was david blaine question mark and
we still laugh about that was it really
david he's dee blaine i'm a big magic
fan i love magic yeah i i i did a bit
about it about how i don't understand
why it's like lame to like magic oh no
no no it is not lame but it is sort of
like well you had derek how do you
pronounce his last name delgado delgadio
yeah
i you saw in and of itself i didn't see
it um live i saw the the sp the taped
version on television on my television
screen
on a screen
and i'll tell you a little secret that
i'm about to tell
all 30 people that listen just kidding
just for just a friend to burn
he didn't need it
and i
instantly i instantly fell in love with
him like to the point where i was like
oh this is a big crush yeah yeah i have
a really good ass chipmunk cheeks love
it give it to me give it all to me
that's what i'm saying
something about and i don't know
anything about him his life i don't
[__] care i was like you're hot
because of his connection to his magic
it was a huge turn on well you can't see
that show i saw it twice sorry um did
you write in the book the book was
better
oh i see right in the book there is
something special about writing out i
think the second time i saw it i was his
friend and i picked the card friend and
he went you are a friend and i was like
and i got moist i want to know
how
he
does
that i want to know and i also don't
want to know um by the way maya and i
would say this to derek that is pick a
card any card just writ large that's all
that is really i don't mean to
i would say this is two different i
don't even know how pick a card any card
works that's the fun and i won't teach
you how
do you do it do you practice i'm an
amateur
but not good i know four
great card tricks but they're great
and i think every day will you do one
for me at some point in our lives yeah
yeah um i did know the wonderful ricky j
ricky j was great
of course you did he was the voice of
magnolia oh he's wonderful and um uh
yeah i mean that's that's no he's in a
bunch of them but i know him first and
foremost oh yeah these things happen
like when you said people think it's
like
that man
well you know the ice block story of
ricky jay no
you know i don't know anything right did
we have we not covered hung out then
with a man
who
[Music]
there's a famous trick i'm sorry i
didn't mean interrupt but you're gonna
love this i'm with you
there's an old old magic trick called
the ice block trick which is you and i
are talking it would this is how i would
do the ice block trick to you and
imagine if i did just for one second and
i went maya and there was a block of
not melting frozen ice right there yeah
and i just leave and you're and you just
so that's the ice block trick and you
just leave well
because i'm just like mic drop
what i'm saying is and this is this is
historical it's like hundreds of years
maybe 100 years old yes old old trick
but you know nobody really knows how to
do it ricky j was having lunch with
someone like at the new york times or
something
they were eating at the end of the meal
they're looking at their dessert menu
and he lifts his menu up and there's a
block like a 30 pound block of ice on
the table and ricky j just leaves and
the inner the woman that was
interviewing him said that she just wept
for 10 minutes oh
that's magic why are people so resistant
it brings you into the moment it goes
let me show you what you think is
it isn't and then it makes you go what
else am i wrong about
what he's such a thoughtful interesting
storyteller and human being and yes he's
not on this earth with us anymore
any time he spoke about anything it was
fascinating and he
you know knew his history
uh and knew he knew that trick i mean it
took the care of someone to go some
people used to do this i'm gonna figure
out how to do it again because he loved
it he loved it so much and he and he
shows that love in the way that he did
it right i just
yeah i got to i got to see him up close
through a card into a watermelon
oh
very fun very fun yeah yeah magic is
great i don't know why people give it
such a heart i do know why because we
like to be the thing
in this culture
that
we want to impact reality we don't want
to have reality changed on us
forgive me for repeating myself but have
you noticed that tough guys don't dance
in action movies because dancing is
submitting your will it's it's feminine
i'm not saying it's for girls only but
there's something receiving about it and
magic is it's asking you to be receiving
yes and to be befuddled and this is why
hackathons oh so it makes a fool of you
you're a fool you have to be willing to
go like oh i don't understand and we
want to be jason bourne we i know where
all the exits are i know where the guns
are and all this stuff and this is what
most and this is why hecklers are
typically guys or or women with a lot of
masculine energy that don't like that a
comedian is is manipulating their
reality changing their chemistry i love
that with with
magic i don't like it with comedy in
terms of
those shows where people go up to people
on the street and
they're pretending to be something and
then i make a fool of you and they trick
them and they and i trick you i don't
like it either i don't like it it makes
me really uncomfortable and it it hurts
my feelings a little bit well i would
rather everyone be in on it yep and it
can make me really uncomfortable to
watch
pranks i don't like pranks yeah
i don't like lying
even if it's for like like they asked me
to do crank yankers and i i said yes
because i oh but you felt guilty a
little bit but then i immediately said
no no i was like i can't call and call
some old woman who works at like whole
foods and she answers the phone and i'm
like do you have venison
i need venison did she have it
i didn't do it no you are the queen i
thought it was real i know
have you ever almost died
uh yes tell me
well i i i could have
you mean like did i get close to the
light
no no no not an nde as they're known
near-death experience but maybe when you
were a kid were you ripped out in a rip
tide oh sure anything like that oh sure
uh i was on a horse once and the horse
got spooked and took off and my dad was
like oh
[Laughter]
well when we cut to you it's in real
time he's in slow motion i don't want to
micromanage but you're like
you're knocking apples off trees
[Laughter]
no that did happen but how did it stop
i think did you reach it i think
somebody caught up with me i don't
remember i was once driving up to my my
dear friend uh brook clayman and i were
driving up to college you know brooke
clayman no it's just a joke it was so
impressive oh wow
well clearly you're not as cool as i
thought you were um this guy knew brook
clayman brooke is a wonderful family
friend
known for many years and i wanted
someone to drive up back to college with
me i went to uc santa cruz and it's a
long drive and i i don't like big drives
by myself yeah especially i was a young
man horseback especially in horseback
i had my had my jetta my my my jedi i
had a jetta it was it stick
no
well
keep it crispy
too many times now um
yeah we uh we were on the two-lane thing
i was driving and then like a semi
i don't know what happened but somebody
came my lane and i veered but you're
supposed to like turn into the swerve
but i just didn't and so the car just
like
did a did a 180 and so i was driving
backwards on the oh on the
highway and i remember looking at the
semi and the semi looking at me and i
was just like going backwards and then
and then i gone back around the other
180 and then we just kind of went
and went to the curb and we were just
sort of like frozen i think it's because
my car was so packed down with all my
[__] for my apartment that i was
thinking about yeah so we just
we should have flipped
like kitty litter that's what i always
say
and um and it just got quiet because you
know when you get scared like i i didn't
hear any sound but then slowly i started
hearing what was on the radio and it was
like
don't do worry butterfly yeah
it was we were listening to stevie
wonder don't you worry about a thing it
was so perfect and weird it was such a
weird life experience and it came back
on just so loud
so it had been blasting i didn't hear it
at all of course
there are things in movies that are
right yeah you know what anything like
that feels like a movie like when it
goes
yeah like something happens
i love it so much w
everyone does it the ringing is so good
though the ringing is great but i meant
when someone's like um i'm sorry but you
have a week to live
it starts to fall and it starts to fade
out
yeah and then
we can take the resources yes to a
little tonight and the resources of
listening go into grief go into shock
well it's it's fight or flight of course
or freezer friend
have you heard friend
no reuben from all time yeah we hang out
clearly because he's got a red beard i
mean but not a weasley beard
no one no one has a greasy beard get
those [__] walk away those guaca
walkers out of here something i used to
say on stage although i get to get sad
when one of them
almost died am i ruining it for you in
harry potter yeah oh i've seen the
movies they just don't stick
you know why because you know why
because you love the hob do me a fave no
i i yeah i am more of a tolkien are you
did you read the books and that was like
your childhood and then you got into the
movies
just the movies just the movies my dad
was really into the books when we were
kids do me a fave okay
h potter yeah it's too much
it's a it's a a gun
or a sword yeah these are established
realities sure but once you have sticks
that shoot beams of light of varying
strengths yeah uh that are hinged on a
mechanism that we don't understand
magical concentration a question mark
now i have voldemort going like
and harry potter going
i'm like this is bad filmmaking
like it just is i two two people pushing
against each other a car pushing against
something a loud sound but as soon as
it's
i'm like i'm out and that's what harry
potter ultimately is it's like in star
trek there's too much of this
yeah yeah
i stopped watching star trek a long time
ago i i it wasn't for me i was big star
wars ladies i didn't care i didn't
really care about star trek yes but not
that you needed to pick a side but like
it wasn't for me i think you did need i
did pick a side when you are you've
never wasn't i was i on star wars were
you in star wars
were you on star wars i'm gonna start
wheezing
i'm laughing so hard are you on this
original star wars yeah that's just how
i call you 70. weren't you in the
original star wars i'm carrie fisher
what was your show i
is that one of your peeps
i just wanted to be princess leia so i
just like that was the coolest thing in
the world to me yeah like surprise i
wanted i mean it was all that era it was
it was olivia um newton john because of
greece and it was carrie fisher because
of
uh star wars it was all at the same time
slave leia was a little it was a lot oh
i couldn't get it you could oh you mean
on the third one yeah you could hear the
boners there was like a rubbery yeah i
wasn't really paying attention to the
boners i was still little enough that i
was like all right but that was more it
definitely felt more intense yeah
i go for like the white caftan that's my
jam the white captain caftan you know
like her original like it wasn't a
caftan i was just trying one of these it
was a very gauzy dress very 70s yeah
it's just white polyester that's one of
my favorite things is like the aesthetic
of the original movies is the 70s like
it's got the flared helmets as it should
be but now we make them and it's like
but it's still the future as established
as by the 70s which is wonderful it is
fun but it's also funny to be like
people don't even know that that shit's
the 70s i love it so much you like it i
do i love the 70s quite a bit i feel
very lucky to have been alive during
that time you also got to pretend to be
in the 70s with an afro
are you talking about licorice licorice
beets licky peeps lecky petes licky
peeps yeah because they didn't relax i
relax my hair with a keratin treatment
and they did not do that in the 1970s
black women you relaxed your hair
without dara wait i relax my hair with a
keratin treatment in real life and
ladies did not do that in the 70s so i
put a wig on but nobody else in the
movie is wearing a wig
i felt that like i was watching oh
except for lucy i guess they call me
magic and everybody's got the natural
that's just what they were doing
my mom had a natural but then later on
she would do like a curler or blow out
kind of thing
a hot set if you will
hot curlers have you ever i bet the
answer is yes i'm gonna pre-pre-load you
with that i can't wait
so i'm just gonna say it with confidence
tell me about a time that you went to a
psychic and they blew your mind you just
really
really think you went to a psychic and
they were like maya you're gonna meet
paul or something like that kristin wig
and i went to a psychic and got the
worst
reading we've ever had and the lady
called us giggling girlfriends
and then um
she was a she was a medium
and and i felt so badly um
she was about a medium
we went down we were like i feel like we
went to
i wanted to say san diego but it was not
that far
but it was definitely like close to
orange county and it was a white lady
and i prefaced that because when she was
a medium
she had a very offensive voice that i
refused to do on your podcast it was
that gnarly i understand i might do it a
little bit but it was like it was like
oh
ah i see you giggling girlfriend
and i was like why is this you're
quoting why is this white lady talking
like this but that was when she was the
me when she was the other she was a
medium she was speaking through oh she
was a ch uh she had channeled channeled
yeah and i forgot what the channel's
name was so it was this this meeting was
referenced just by somebody like if you
are just a racist person
or and you just want to do just get away
with it be like i'm gonna look it's a
jambalaya cook from new orleans it's not
me
it's a jive talking pimp from the 70s
just hang loose blood
she gonna catch you on the rebound on
the medic side
then you come back as a white guy
not me it's not me he's coming back hey
job turkey i just wanted to say jeff
turkey
hey
that's basically what it felt like okay
yeah and she was wrong about everything
i think
it was pretty funny well i'm glad i
asked anytime i've see and i love i'm
like give it to me i get nervous because
you know i get scared about like spooky
things well i yep i like it but i get a
little i get a little nervous and i saw
i saw someone i got my tarot cards read
in salem at one of those wonderful
crystal shops yes i wonder if it was the
same one that i went to well interesting
because when i think because at the time
i was like the [__] was that
and in retrospect i she did say i was
going to have another baby and i did wow
my fourth but like at the time i had
three and i was like i'm not having
another baby yeah this this [__] greg
this [__] cray this [__] cray
this [__] cry
that's what it's from yeah very hard
song to ask alexa to play oh god what a
wonderful song yeah that song i'm gonna
i'm gonna ask you to laugh at that very
hard song to ask alexa to play
try it
alexa
i refuse
you have to say
n words in paris and then you know what
she says now playing n words in paris
does she say n words she does and i was
like i knew alexa was white
oh my god what if she says n words yeah
the song is not called n words in paris
but that's cool alexa is not about to
get killed she does not repeat it if you
say it oh i've never tried saying it i'm
gonna go home and say it the regular i
won't say it in your house i won't
pollute your alexa you can it's with the
a
that's true i don't mean you like we
don't have like an open policy with that
there's a note by the front i'm like i
feel like you can is what i'm saying go
for it i don't i don't like saying that
word yeah i don't like saying the the
real n word and i don't um
i remember because growing up mixed like
no one ever had a name for it i felt
like i was like i'm mixed like
people weren't mixed when i was in the
semi
i knew like two mixed kids and they were
all musicians kids all musicians kids
were mixed and i was like oh i guess
that's normal
and then uh
someone said so then i learned about the
term mulatto which is a horrific term
but everyone was using it like yeah this
is what you're supposed to use and it
basically is like
the definition of like donkey like a
mule is is a cross between a donkey and
an a between a horse and a donkey is a
is a mule right so it's just saying that
really you're a mule oh no yeah it's
terrible that's like in the 70s also in
the 70s when you're saying that word we
were also saying the hard r word we're
saying the hard r word we're saying
oriental we were saying quite a few
things it was a [__] crazy it was a
[__]
[__] show it was a [__] [__] but you
know what we had a lot of fun oh my god
we're smoking cigarettes on a plane oh
we'll be right back we had a lot of fun
though god we were talking about that
the other day i know i love to talk
about the fact that like we could smoke
on cigarettes and places we could smoke
on something you guys want to smoke just
that like us
is out there smoking on cigarettes just
remember as children like being like i
gotta go to the bathroom and then
walking through the smoking section to
the bathroom of course but there wasn't
a curtain and even if there had been a
curtain that wouldn't have kept kept you
from this moment on the airplane yes
yeah that's just getting recirculated
yes you're in marlboro country you're
flying over marlborough you're actually
you are
marlboro country nobody marlboro hi i
have an idea for a cigarette company all
right let's hear it it's called
marlborough
okay everyone's gonna have a really easy
time pronouncing it when that's the word
aurora is it hot in here it gets a
little toasty no i can open the door
again it's fine i don't want you to do
anything i'm asking because i genuinely
want to know if i'm having a hot flash
katie levine but i find myself saying it
a lot more lately and i think i'm
reading into the fact that i'm turning
50 as opposed to like have you hit 49 no
i think i'm perry
perry perry menopause what does that
mean forever fertile it means
i'm like a forever puppy i just stay
fertile forever are you forever fertile
i'm forever fertile whoa
i probably am no i am uh i'm at that age
where things are starting to slow down
but the shop has not closed so i still
get my period yes but then like weird
[__] will happen where i'm like
oh i haven't had my period for three
months you're in an in between yeah i'm
in the i'm in the i'm in the nether what
is that what's when you're upside down
yeah i'm in the upside down see will you
watch stranger things because it's scary
it's gonna i have watched all of it and
it gets progressively scarier season to
season i agree
i think i feel safe because it's a
television show for some reason but i
don't know
maybe but i also feel like
i i i can camp covers a lot of sins it's
it's the spielbergy camp yeah i can see
that it's not real i didn't like billy
and i didn't like those those people
made out of rats i i that spooked me
quite a bit
billy was the [__] brother of the
redheaded girl yeah i don't know the
names just like i don't know he's a dick
he's dead now don't worry about it he's
dead
i mean not in real life and do you
remember when there's a guy on there
that looks like flanny and he died sean
aston oh sean they got planning
you think sean astin looks like flanny
yeah and so do you know
now i'll never forget it but i don't
think that shawn aston looks like flanny
but now i do but now you
do have you going i don't what now i
just saw it wow a lot of fun
have you ever seen a ghost
no and i have a theory that i never will
because
my mom died when i was little and so i
was like oh she's protecting me because
she knows i'm scared oh she keeps him
away i feel like broom where the with a
ghostbuster have you ever seen a ghost
no
people ask me that my mine's dumb i i
think the ghost of my mom's cat lives in
her house really yeah and i feel it jump
up on the bed why is that dumb you feel
it yeah yeah and i can if i'm real still
and stay asleep it'll come up and curl
up against me stop and it's consistent
it means like i don't stay there that
makes me scared i just want you to know
that and that's why i am
well you scared a clam have you ever
heard the cat or you just feel it i
don't recall hearing it
i'll tell you i'll tell you a little a
little
thing in that i've always been a huh a
nugget i'm going to give you a little
nugget
it's not me it's not me hey man
but fred
that was trey i think i've well i know
i've always been scared of ghosts and i
don't want to see them i'm scared scared
scared
and i shared this with paul and he said
but why don't you see it as a good thing
because that means that our loved ones
may forever yeah and i that helped me a
lot but i'm still i i think i could
maybe be ready but i'm scared that it'll
be like i probably saw poltergeist too
young yeah oh yeah uh you know it's too
young to see poultry guys
49. yeah that's right why are we
watching this [__] it's scary the
exorcist you should watch that never i
can smell her stephen when
when the baby when her daughter goes
into the television and like and then
you hear the music and then there's like
a gust of wind and she's like
ugh steven i can smell her that's
horrible it [__]
terrified me and also made me sad and i
was like oh my god people go away like
and then there was like
birth stuff i did love it though but why
did i watch it the exercise the exorcist
i should not have watched
oh that's everybody it's on the poster
it's the pull quote from the new york
times i shouldn't have watched this that
mean when you do this to me not me oh
not me
please tell me
maybe do this to me though
it's scary it's so scary oh no let's not
even talk about it i did have a bit
about it where i watched it with my
girlfriend at the time um and there's
the scene where she does the crab walk
reverse crab walk down the stairs thank
you does a handstand and then vomits and
my girlfriend for real goes oh i forgot
about that part and i know how do you
forget about that part i would like to
forget about that part i can't pronounce
the only part i had far far forgotten
about fart scots
was um
before she knows before they know that
the devil be inside of her is when her
mom's having a dinner party and she
comes and she's like reagan what are you
doing here and she had peed remember she
pees and it's like there's something
about it that's really strange as
opposed to like scary it's like oh this
doesn't feel right like uh this doesn't
feel right
does she have the headlining devil like
the the main act the main guy in there
is it the main guy or is it like an
offshoot i mean i feel like
it's the devil
i didn't stick around long enough to ask
i was like get me the [__] out of this
theater i was at the others did you see
the others [__] no yeah see i haven't
learned my lesson you need to know now
like anything you need to know
it i'm not watching it yeah med summer
[__] no it follows
which is not about the clown by the way
but but also bye bye i don't i haven't
seen any of your scary movies so i don't
even know any of these references i only
watch
i don't know i watch the ones that i
feel like i have to watch because
everyone's talking about them like what
oh
no i didn't watch it so that's not even
true mid-summer everyone was talking
what about paranormal activity that was
horrible you can't see that yeah that's
a [__]
wimp yeah you're a wimp you're a witch
you i am a but i'm a i'm a nice i'm a
good witch
i got this at wicked okay
um that was a good witch laugh kind of i
have a little bit of a cackling i didn't
mean to burn you there no no i was your
real laugh and i was like good witch
left
i opened the door have you seen the
witch house in beverly hills
there's a witch house in beverly what do
you mean what does that mean
somebody i learned a little bit of the
history and i don't know it but when i
was a kid like we would drive there
because i grew up in westwood and it
wasn't far and so we would go there to
like trick or treat and there was a lady
that lived there and was would dress up
like a witch and give out candy it um
i think that the person that had it
built might have used i don't want to
say imagineers but like people that did
disney things so it's got like it looks
like a wicked witches it's going for
witch it's
perfect it's not just like a sad old
woman oh no no no no it's a she hasn't
mowed the lawn in a while absolutely
yeah it's like keep off poison like if
you see the picture it's beautiful have
you has have you met beyonce and she
liked your impression
i have met beyonce
um but in the early days like when she
was on snl when she was one of the
destiny's children yes and we did a
sketch anna and i did a sketch with
destiny's child because we used to do a
fake destiny's child
band called gemini's twin that was
basically the same
that was like that was the concept their
con the concept of them
having new
band members was
the sketch
the gist of the the sketch
and so we had them on and
very nice and then over the years she'd
come
and at that time fred and i did a prince
show i was just beyonce beyonce come
over the year beyonce's come over the
years beyonce's have come and beyonce's
have gone
but there's only one beyonce
beyonce knowles carter
the one and only
but so i she was on and then i did her
while she but she wasn't she she wasn't
in it was in front of her so it was
embarrassing so i saw it good nights and
i said i'm so embarrassed that i did you
in front of you and she was like no no
that was good
but i
i
feel like those were the early days and
then since then i get nervous because i
love her so much that i want her
i wanna i i pray
always that she likes it but i i don't
know if she does yeah but i feel like
i've heard her talk like oh yeah she
talks like me but i i don't that was a
long time ago so i just i get a little
nervous because i don't like to make fun
of people right i don't like i don't do
impressions to like to make fun of
people like
i'm holding up the mirror to show you
what i'm going to do
it's full homage it's like i know how to
talk like you because i love you
jinx
oh no the jinx rubberturst
did you watch that you mean fred fred
armisen as robert doesn't
know but doesn't it look like oh he did
yeah
it looks like a fred character
oh my god remember when he burps
it's also you did it exactly
what does that mean
that i did it obviously what the [__]
with the burps i mean
if that's not a a
physical reaction of the body actually
reacting together that's what frogs are
to who did david blaine kill
if you're burping up
[__]
what the lights flickered whoever
d-plain killed
wait did he kill somebody
david david
but wait david's alive so that means
whoever did that okay so you asked me if
i've ever seen a ghost no but i [__]
love when that happens yeah i love it
and then i talk to it a little bit okay
did david did david blaine kill you
oh thank god
cause he's gargling up frogs and we need
i mean i don't know him i'm sure dee
blaine i don't know dee blaine i have no
horse in this race i'm just i'm just
asking
did
were you killed
or are you dead
nothing nothing nothing but now i can
only see light bulb when i look at you
that was that was wild has that happened
before no
you know why
because i'm here yeah maybe some maybe
something happened because i'm here
doing the royal made me realize that's
andre the giant
and this is my andre the giant it's
asking carl reiner
uh i forget what he says he goes miss
rhino
mr ryan
that's so good
you guys come on over you want to say
bonjour
[Laughter]
do you guys want to say bones rule oh my
god that's andre the giant noticing that
people are kind of like they want to say
hi to him you want to say bonjour come
on over you want to be french
yeah say his name is andre
anglais it never occurred to me because
i am friends
frank's braille is not made for me i
only thought his name was andre the
giant i never thought about his last
name what's his last name
his last name is lebron he's married
he's married to simon lebron from durand
that means he would sometimes be like
hey
[Music]
he would like talk about it to his
french friends
that is the best one i've ever heard
really yeah i haven't heard a lot of
them but that one's really good
you know what i love the uh
i haven't heard a lot of them do you
know what i love more than anything for
real tell me for no reason every once in
a while i'll get tickled by the thought
of my name is aniga montaya yeah you
kill my father prepare to die why does
that make you laugh wonderful but it's a
that's a tingle it's something about it
is funny that like he can't stop saying
it and it just gets louder yeah hello
hello you forgot hello
my name is that part makes me that's why
it's funny to me and i drop the hello
that's why i should never do stand up
hello
my name is
i'm sorry i shouldn't be doing this
voice
it's a little pacino
oh my god oh my god
you want more it's really good so
am i just now discovering that you can
do impressions of anyone this point in
the conversation yeah that's like a fred
bid did fred do i wanted to go on conan
and say i can do an impression of anyone
and have any people do it because that
is like a fred bit and then it's like
it's like a terrible and then it's a
terrible impression you mean like it's
just like but you try you try in earnest
the problem i don't know a lot of people
but uh you mean in life
no you i'm afraid they'd be like kim
kardashian i just don't know what they
say no no fred would do impressions of
people like the crew like there was a
guy that
when we would have meal break and when
we were doing camera blocking in snl you
would hear him over saying
mailbreak back at five and fred would do
that guy that's
great my best cameras this is my brother
ready
hell dude that's my brother it's perfect
you know it's perfect
that's your best impression it's a shame
also just the words hey dude hey dude
yeah oh that's cute hey dude i saw you
had my rudolph on the show dude
that is
and my parents i do it for them and
they're like huh i'm like
you're the only two people that should
get it that actually kind of drives me
crazy i don't know if it drives you
crazy and not in a way where i get mad
but like do you ever notice that thing
where you're like you know something's
absolutely right and people are like huh
yeah that drives me a little crazy i
absolutely know because it's exactly
that i don't like it i also do my father
maya ruler what what was the most
important part of that's how you're
dancing
really yeah
wow it's insane how does your mom talk
well the essence of how she talks is my
life i don't care for her
the way that she does the voices she
doesn't like it she doesn't she doesn't
like my words hormone monster okay how
outrageous
those two people are married
unfortunately that's wild yeah and they
i counsel them do i it's not going great
pillar
you're like guys uh i'm your son
but but also who else are we gonna talk
to i guess i guess he's right i mean do
they live in boston yeah still well they
live in arlington oh they live in
arlington you know arlington i can't you
know where rachel jacques is from she's
lexington she's from lexington
and the same high school you did yeah
together she's no no no she's older than
you
uh yeah she was older because you're
younger than me that's right she's my
senior as well yeah like if we were all
in high school together yeah yeah she's
she's quite old
we'd say two camera
she's um she's an octogenarian
she went to um lexington and she and amy
poehler always have a fun um like
your high school sucks thing because
she's from burlington yeah
yeah i don't know what i mean by this
but amy poehler to me when i see her
she just looks like massachusetts to me
really and nobody else i don't think
other people see that but that is what
girls looked like in my eyes i never
heard her with her boston accent she
said she had a very thick one but i
never heard it i believe it rachel
doesn't look like she's from lexington
yeah she looks like she's
from kansas she looks like she's to me
she looks like um
like from like lithuania like she could
be from our our yes our part of town i
want to see her go i have passion flop
like that's the perfect she definitely
has pigeons i will shave you while you
sleep
keep the gods away is that how they talk
in lithuania yeah
i've never been have you no
i've never been it's not how they
talking about it well you sound like
grew from uh
uh so oh you're you only have a three
and a half year old well good news
you're about to see every animated film
that's ever been made in the next for
the next 10 to 15 years of your life
what was it like being married to jim
gaffigan um
pretty great 100 jk what if i thought
you guys had to like we got really
married we got married in order to like
feel it out here's the hot questions
hot ryan gosling we always end by and i
just want to respect your time look i'll
do this all day we haven't sung
in unison yet oh yeah thank you thank
you close with that
but before that
do you have any any religion
spirituality feelings we just here's why
i'm asking it's not to be like my
runoff's an atheist or a click bait
oh i'm waiting for the click bait
here's pete claiming he's quoting moshe
casher who's clearly a fake name just so
he could [__] on lithuania in world war
ii we just told we just told the world
that david blaine murdered somebody
that's right be clear but yeah because
the light flicker derek delgadio has
chipmunk chinks this is what it is
and he made us moist yeah he did yeah no
that show is sexy as hell right yeah
jesus christ keep it in your pants room
what do you mean and he can cut to any i
mean he's one of the best mechanics
that's the term
really yeah card mechanic
there's something called the mechanics
grip my mouth is
a gape if you see john dituro who i'm
assuming is your dear friend
just because he's a new york guy i'm
assuming you mean the actor yeah he'd
come by snl er lorne i can't do him i
can't do him no one can do him nope he
can barely do him nope he can't do it at
all it's in rounders he goes i knew a
boy was cheating when i saw him with the
mechanic's grip ed norton ketchuping a
hot dog with his finger oh my god he was
in the scene are you serious
you love movies that much too that you
watch them over and over again constant
ask me how many times i've seen twbb
how many times have you seen twbb i'm
embarrassed it's too many to count how
many
it's in the it's not in the triple
digits but it's in the high double
digits really oh yeah
and that's a long movie
that movie is an exceptional movie that
was the first movie that paul actually
made
when i knew him he had already made
puncher glove when i met him but and he
was editing it so i wasn't around when
he was shooting it so
um there will be blood um our daughter
was eight months old and we went to
marfa and we were like and marfa is a
trippy place martha texas yes marfa
texas that's where you bought upton
sinclair's oil exclamation point oh he
he had oil already and that's why you
went to martha we went to martha so he
could film um
to make them to film it yes okay i
thought you took a day trip to martha
honey do you want to go to my family
with her baby that's where there will be
uh that's where no country was as well
oh yes don't don't twbb there will
be baby
i just made that up don't put it in your
pocket
because then it's just another coin
which of course it is does he say that
that's in um
no country
oh see
you watch a lot of more movies and i
don't see no country i have i've seen it
do you are you asking me if i remember
it just go ahead and watch it again yeah
i mean i really enjoyed it you go like
wow that was a really good
center
oh that was javier
but you sounded like john huston just
now
john hughes john houston
not john hughes who's maybe one of my
favorite directors really
have you met me which is your least
favorite pta movie i'm just kidding
oh my gosh
can you imagine it would be fun it was
it was one of those things that were
like it it was weird to meet him because
i already loved his movie so that was
that was a little bit i'm really like
because val's a like a fan like she
likes my work and i think that really i
felt embarrassed but then i didn't know
but it didn't
didn't make things weird but it wasn't
but it was a little bit creepy but you
probably saw i believe i've heard
forgive and forget that there's like a
three-hour cut of there will be blood
and i was like can i please watch that
there's a three-hour cut of it somebody
said that they went to a screening like
a friend screening to give notes oh so
you mean early on before you trim
trimmed out i don't mean like it's on
itunes or this guy would already have
seen it i mean there's like a reel
somewhere i'm sure i mean
i'm sure you're trying to plant this for
your fifties a birthday present i get it
i'm saying you've seen it you have well
i must have seen it in all its um
iterations for sure but i don't remember
you know what
here's a fun fact i don't remember a lot
of things yeah i don't know if i've told
you that i love it
um i don't remember how long it was but
yes i've seen all the iterations
yes is it ever awkward when you're like
not for me
um i mean how are you yes but i've never
felt that way but when i when i did see
there will be blood i
uncontrollably wept afterwards and had
and like could not
could not come back from it for a while
like
it was it was
done-ish but like wasn't completely done
but it was the first time i really saw
it we were in new york at the time
because i dragged poor paul and our baby
back to do more snl
and he had to edit it there and um
i
i uncontrollably wept
at um at daniel plainview's
horrible heart like it hurt me it hurt
me to see
which way he went it it upset me so much
and i couldn't come back from it for a
really long time yeah it was really wild
no that's actually a beautiful thing for
you to say because that it's like when
people love
um patrick bateman the american psycho
these things are supposed to be
skewering these characters right right
like it's weird that we're like that's
my guy daniel playing you that's my god
you mean i'm sure some it's somebody's
guy for sure but i call my ego my plane
view do you really yeah so you don't
like paul's movies at all
it's psychologically helpful to go
that's just my plane view yeah meaning
we all have a part of us that's like
absolutely i'll kill my
this guy for anything like it's it's
grotesque but it's the animal yeah yeah
we're animals we are we're mammals we're
both we make milk and we fart we do make
milk we make milk and get it let me tell
you something it's awesome
that you make milk yeah it's so great
like the feeling of it oh nursing is the
best thing in the world i know val had a
we're really hoping for number two right
now oh that but but well i pro let me
preface that by saying let me let me
rewind and say not everybody nurses and
i'm not here to go oh um
why don't you nurse no no no i didn't
it just didn't go great it's such a
stressful thing it's so stressful for
yourself coming over and squeezing i had
a coach for my son because he had
jaundice and like we couldn't hey
jaundice oh they put you under the
little mcmuffin
mcmuffin lamp
and um he was born in july and he was so
sleepy he'd fall asleep on the boob
he was just a small guy he'll never be
happier than that oh he was just just
john is hot from that it's so hot i just
have to take his shirt off and tickle
him to keep him awake falling asleep
but it's there's something that you
release that's very that's very peaceful
from it but um
my girlfriends that also had children
around the same time some of them that
did not have a good time with it it's
brutally stressful it's a bummer and i
hate the
the idea that we're all supposed to like
do it a certain way like
i think people think because i have four
children that like i promote something
you have something but like that i like
i have four children i do have four
children but the truth is like i just
want people to be happy of course you
know like do it it is a sensitive
subject but i think you're also free to
say that you loved it and that it was it
sounds like i loved it but i know it's
not for everyone and i i know how hard
it is and there by the way
i don't know if you called her but there
was an amazing
um
lactation nurse that i used uh called my
mobile coach still laughing at you
saying you don't like paul's movies at
all do you that was very funny and very
quick little switchblade right there
my like yeah i think she did use that
lactation coach um she's very good linda
yeah i remember linda she she grabbed my
wife's breasts okay well i was just sort
of like did she do this the sandwich
hold the sandwich grip yeah that's
that's all subway sandwich grip the
subway sandwich grip yeah hungry girl's
choice so
any spiritual leanings
i was not my parents my dad was not
raised
going to hebrew school and my mom was
raised i think presbyterian and was and
they both decided that they did not
practice religion but they used to tell
me when i was little like
it's whatever you believe like they were
very
open
and so i never it's really interesting
my grandfather my dad's father
sid rudolph
was kind of a self-proclaimed atheist he
was jewish but he was a self-proclaimed
atheist and he used to say he had a lot
of quotes he was not a famous man but in
our family he was famous for some reason
and he used to say things like your
rules don't rule us he was just very
like he didn't like being told what to
do yes i like your rules don't roll your
rules don't rule us he also said um it's
like mad men where he goes you're born
alone you die alone and the world slaps
a bunch of rules on you to make you
forget that but i never forget god
you've got jesus who
who has isms like my grandfather always
used to also used to say um the park is
filled with dead joggers
the park is filled with dead jobs he
didn't like to exercise
wow he was like pre-peloton he's like
yeah he was really like
i got your jug right here he was a funny
funny man but he did not like religion
and then why not say the morgue is
filled with a lot of people that should
have gone because
oh i'm supposed to exercise yeah the
[__] park's filled with dead joggers
like
i know that's a very it's very said
rudolph it's a little uh
it's a lot it's a lot well you clearly
haven't dined with sid rudolph or the
other guy that's cut rudolph his son
yeah that's his son yeah my dad's
brother wow
i'm getting a they're the best there's a
lot of apples on this family tree this
is the rudolph treat but when i did my
um i the reason i know a lot of my
genealogy is i did the genealogy show
finding your roots and they do such
beautiful extensive genealogy research
and so they did six months of research i
had no idea her family was from she'll
know yeah by the way yeah she's watching
that show our family's from lithuania
but specifically vilnius and that our
name was not rudolph it was rude of
chevsky
so that's why he's like you know they
made it
red no it's rain goat
exactly
it's a goat it's not a deer a rain god
it's a goat with santa and his bag of
coals like clothes for the good for the
good kids and it's so interesting that
you that's the that's your lithuanian
accent and i think it's just eastern
europe yeah but i fully believed it the
first time you did it and now i'm like
is it you don't necessarily pink that's
lithuanian it means don't worry about it
so when i yeah so when i'd go my family
my mother's family speaks lithuanian for
christmas and stuff and i just learn
nessarupink which means don't worry
about it that makes you sound smart
well the the the gist of it and i'm
clearly long-winded is that
i found out that our family built the
synagogue in lithuania which i found so
fascinating because it was
my grandfather's
father's family that built the synagogue
that definitely doesn't sound like
something that makeup to make you feel
like you didn't waste your time doing
that stupid show
what show
wait wait show oh finding your own god i
thought you were doing a bit also no i
love the show yeah i know you loved it
oh my god the show was so what if i
thought they made that up i'm just
kidding they definitely what if we found
find out like 10 years later that all
those shows are just literally just like
just throw that in there yeah and uh
your dad's best friend was hemingway
well that's what it felt like when i did
the um the genie the dna stuff like the
23andme for my dog did you ever do that
for your dog yeah you could do like a
jean thing for your dog what are you
looking for snoopy what are you going in
there looking for mama i wanted to know
what he was okay and they told us the
dumbest [__] really yeah like oh
rhodesian ridgeback and you know uh
shih tzu and i was like he's a pit mix
it when my dad did it
and it's always it's just so a lot of
white people can be like you know i'm a
little bit cherokee yeah it's just like
it's very funny that was actually the
big joke on that because i was always
told because black families also are
always told that we're part native
american and i asked him and he said
everybody asks and he turned the page
and was like zero
but but there's it's so fascinating
because we're definitely the age where
we were brought up by people who
did it happen again
david wait but we were talking about
ancestors and native americans and it
happened what's going on pete it's
haunted this is a haunted jack shack
your jack shout out jack back here this
is a jack shack
this is a jack jack
is that what you call paul tom's editing
bay you and your jack shack honey oh
yeah working on the cot are you on the
jack shaft
it's time for dinner
put down the three-hour cod there will
be blood that you unearth for pete's
50th and get down here you've got plenty
of time you're not there yet
yeah that's true you have seven years to
find those canisters
hit it
god do is there one
i
i feel that there is
a moment did i do you went
you asked me i'll try to be you
god is there
i
think there is
i think there is a yeah i think there is
a thing
i don't know what it is but i do i do
talk to whatever it is
sometimes i don't have any sort of like
place i go or organization but i
definitely feel that
i am part of something much larger than
myself
that um
similar to the way that we um that
babies come into this world like the i
just i when i was pregnant i marveled at
the human body i was like wow this thing
this machine is incredible yes it really
takes care of itself that's kind of how
i feel about the universe and life and
what whatever god is and for me god is
nature and the the universe and
i talk to it sometimes like it's a
person but it doesn't feel like any
specific thing to me yeah
that's right out of my brain god is no
thing
yeah
it's not a thing it's it's not a man in
the sky it's it's it's more of a verb as
people sometimes say i like that i like
that and then i i think
i think because i was a kid when my mom
died
i got
a lot of like imagery in my head of
heaven and angels and all that stuff so
i sort of used to associate like god
with
my mom is with god or people would say
things to me but um
i think whatever
that is is
i do i do believe paul's right i do
believe it's a hopeful thing that maybe
she's
with the big man upstairs somewhere
there's there's something good happening
because here's my thing here's my my
theory
what a [__] jip
that we
we get we get to come
on this planet right we get to be alive
we get to inhabit this wonderful body
that we're given and then we make people
or find people that we love more than
anything in the world
and then we leave
that's [__] up
that's horrible now i know that i'm
supposed to be appreciative of the time
that i was here that's what i was going
to say really truly
truly like
i find as as each day goes by and
definitely since i became a parent
that really the only thing that floats
my boat most is
the people that i love and these people
that are
breathing outside of my body and i just
can't get enough of how wonderful they
are
why then are we supposed to just go
bye-bye
it's so [__] up um i mean we talk
about this on the show a lot
the way we phrase it is would ice cream
taste good if you lived forever
i feel like if you look at adam and eve
as a story of human beings
remember we eat from the tree of good
and evil this is just a story by the way
but you eat from good and evil
uh so as soon as you have life as soon
as you have incarnation you have you
have death
they define one another light defines
dark joy defines sorrow so we're stuck
we we left the garden of eden which is
where everything that's where your son
was when he was passing out nursing and
just so warm and happy that's where we
that's where we were there i think there
was a time when we were in the
indivisible unborn unmanifest god but
god wanted to play
that's what my daughter's name means
leela it means the play
of god the play of life the dance as
well so it risks
even something as horrible as death
because it knows that when your car spun
around and went backwards and you heard
that stevie wonder song that that
feeling
was like electricity in a way that it
wouldn't be if you didn't almost die
you know what i'm saying it wants
that's what's so beautiful about
storytelling and film and stuff is it's
making meaning of this system
of this thing that we're stuck in
but that is what i think is going on it
gives this it's like telling a story it
has to have stakes this conversation
matters more
you choosing to come here and do it
matters more that our time is finite and
our future is unpromised and it just
sort of imbues everything with this it's
really i think you're absolutely right i
think what what breaks my heart is
seeing the the physical form fall apart
sure like watching
older people and pain like all that and
then we appreciate more right like you
get let's be honest some filmmakers make
very different movies when they get
older than they do when they're younger
right yeah i know you're waiting for
that 85 year old pta movie you're like
and i'm gonna see it on 35. that's right
oh
that says oh maybe 70 pete let's be
honest maybe 70 mil
look i'll see it in the dome if it
reopens oh why what's wrong i mean
what's wrong with los angeles why are
why don't they preserve their history
why don't he lose all the great
directors in this town donate point zero
five percent i agree with them i agree
with that and i do think that why didn't
green day save cbgb like i i'm just like
i don't understand i'm with you on that
by the way yes you know what i've always
wanted to do for real because i grew up
in westwood is i want to save westwood
village because it was
the [__] yeah when i was growing up yeah
and it's a college town and there was
like individual theaters and then you
could walk and go to the arcade or you
could get food or whatever but it was
alive and fun and like no reason why but
it's just never like it's never come
back so i'm here on your podcast to
petition to save new york to six and
westwood oh save the arclight both the
hollywood and the sherman oaks and um
and westwood yeah yeah there's a lot my
children are definitely being raised to
appreciate film actual film and that uh
and it's i mean look at our lifetime
it's it's dying it's a dying art actual
dying art you know most of those
theaters are just
digital projections there's no film
people don't know how to
how to load reels yeah your kids are
cutting load
how old are your kids forget it
35 80
and 1. it's just a weird thing when you
do have boys and they reach an age
you're like
it's happening
i i don't know that age yet yeah i have
a little whatever you think it is
subtract seven i'm just kidding i had a
woman say well we were talking about
having teenagers and she said and a mom
older than me and she said whatever you
think they're doing subtract two years
they're doing it earlier well
bummer
you've bummed me out
totally bummed me out
thanks a lot you totally bummed me out
i regret this egg sound you can change
it it was too hard
i thought we were doing our echo thing
now that we'll sing in unison okay let's
do it
um i loved your god answer by the way
for what it's worth thank you i love
talking about it and i i i used to be
afraid to talk about it and i i think i
was i was so scared of
death dying talking about death talking
about any life any of it when i was a
kid i was so scared amaya your mom died
when you were 17. seven
17.
[Laughter]
oh my god
that was
full wheeze that was great
correcting you
on the age your mother died that you
were you really got me um loved it
what i mean is
once your mom dies and you're seven
um and i don't mean to be speaking so
casually you're doing great okay i'm
just saying the rest of your life after
that point if somebody has some goofy
afterlife theory they're talking about
someone you love it's yeah it's not a
it's not a thought experiment right you
know what i'm saying yes absolutely so i
feel the same way like
i have a joke where i go i believe in
god but i hate when other people believe
in god because i don't know which god
they're talking about yeah could be one
of the weird [__] up ones that's
that's that's doing horrible things i
agree with you i i like i like the idea
of everybody
got their own thing it's okay
well what i hear in that is
oh boy don't get me started but we tend
to we have three more hours
[Music]
softballs
football has lines and guards
[Laughter]
all i know is when i was in high school
i worked at chili jilly's frozen yogurt
and i served george carlin frozen yogurt
was really cool little ponytail oh
i believe the ponytail was gone by that
point okay
there's an older carlin oh oh see
what i'm saying you're saying you love
the diversity of belief well i just you
know why because what i'm really saying
is don't tell me what to do yeah that's
why i love it a lot of dead joggers in
the park
yeah no but for real i'm free to do
i'm free to feel how i feel and so is
everybody but it is that's exactly
what's beautiful people want me to feel
yes a certain way that actually you know
what that scares me i think because that
is from childhood there was something
that i did cut you off and you were like
all right i certainly wasn't i was like
look at you you're doing a good job
getting the guests to talk no i just i i
i think i i think i was a little weirded
out by like going to church when we'd go
home to chicago to see my mom's family
because i didn't understand it
no one helped me understand it i just
like was thrown in cold so it was very
overwhelming and i felt it made me
nervous because i felt like i'm supposed
to know what's going on and i didn't
sing to skinny bloody guy yeah i didn't
understand experience and it somehow
always equated with my mom and it all
felt a little scary so that wasn't great
for me it's scary in like a death way
not my mom i love my mother but i wasn't
very afraid of all this
mystery of life and all that stuff and
so i sort of put it all away now i'm
like bring it on yeah let's sit down
with it yeah
come on in that's great i mean i don't
know why what what else am i going to do
why waste your time pushing stuff away i
mean i'm still a scaredy cat about a lot
of stuff in life yeah like i'm not
someone who's gonna
just start rock climbing tomorrow i
don't think i'd be very good at that and
i'm probably not gonna see any of the
scary movies we were talking about but
like i'm definitely more open to stuff
that used to kind of freak me out well i
mean sorry to keep bringing it up but
you were wounded they start um
the age of the wound you know in the
child's life there's the innocence and
then there's the wound and the age of
seven yeah which is when like the
archetypal wound happened so you had
like a real so it's not like
cute or yeah like let's just kind of
talk like it had happened to you yeah so
of course you were guarded but now
you've matured and you've ripened and
you're a plum
like i'm confused and you're a plum and
you brought us plums
nectarines oh nectarines forgive me tell
me if they're tell me do you like
nectarines or do you hate them i'm sorry
did you just call me an [__] yes i
love nectarines they're [__]
delicious what i want you to do before
you eat them is smell them they smell
like [__] heaven i smell books i'm
gonna be smelling everything smell my
neck dreams a lot
can i get just because it
i love this right
we're like glasses of water and god's
like an ocean and when we die the water
just goes back into the ocean the form
is gone but the essence because it goes
nowhere that's what i was saying before
about like this body that we like we we
get to this is the glass of water i mean
like how the [__] did this happen that's
what joseph campbell says his
spirituality is realizing you're not the
light bulb you're the light
you're the light
and we're all the light but i think i'm
still
holding on to something that's like
but are we going to see each other again
like i really really get i get too too
precious about it and i have to i have
to i would love to make peace with that
before i go night night forever yeah
because i really don't want to
go into the the darkness like
you know
kicking and screaming i want to be okay
with all of it yeah dr jude did this
podcast and he was like i've been with a
lot of people dying and he's like people
of faith have a much easier time he was
like he's not a person of faith and he's
like i really envy that and i was like
well would you don't you want to crack a
book of a different tradition maybe you
don't like the one you were raised in
but like sometimes when you read another
tradition
taoism for example is a beautiful like
it's all one it's all
for lack of a better word i call it the
dao it's like it doesn't even name it
god it's just like it's all one it's
everything's fine it's all happening
simultaneously it's very comforting yes
so i was going to say that the reason
you're nervous is the same as the other
side of what makes you a beautiful
mother and a friend and all these things
because you appreciate the preciousness
and you want to engage so you're not
ready to push everything away yes and
that's fine
that's that's why the ego is never going
to love
it's never going to love spirituality
really because it it destroys it you
know what you mean it it kills it kills
it off is that also why like as you
watch people get older they're like uh
they're less like i don't know they're
bad yeah that fact is like is that fat
kind of like i've accepted like
i'm on my way
boy i don't know is it just physical
pain i think about it a lot physical
pain is a huge thing yeah oh physical
pain by the way have you noticed my
footwear physical pain has already begun
got a nice note of mustard once you know
once you see this on the side of
someone's shoe you'll be like oh that
person's aging
love it because it's all foot it's all
about feet and we're not even new
yorkers using our feet all the time
we're in cars all the time but it
affects your knees your ankles your yeah
back
i completely understand and i'm gonna do
what snoop dogg did
oh you look great
i couldn't do it that's what he said i
couldn't do it cool oh you look great oh
i'll do denzel that's you this is paul
that's you all right all right that's
okay that's a good dean denzel dean
that's a dean denzel
that was a very i was there for the
the dean edwards years uh-huh
i've seen it all
all right here let's do it do you want
to go and i'll mirror you or do you want
me to go in numerical i've i haven't
thought about this i haven't thought
about this yet ready you'll follow me
and then i'll follow you
[Music]
call your dad dad
and tell him
[Music]
[Applause]
spinning
there's witches in that house
[Music]
yeah snoop dogg always said
keep it in your pants
[Music]
you looked like you were 12 years old
when you realized
a bit like it was the most purist thing
that is how i feel when i'm having fun
making funnies i feel like
yeah yeah well that's the freedom that
sorry to make it spiritual but we are in
the spiritual part there's a my favorite
jesus quote is unless you become like a
little child you won't enter the kingdom
of heaven and i'm like so it's not about
being angry and being right and and
being righteous and
making other people believe it's about
being like a little child and you know
that when you're in that space pure it's
pure it's and and back to what i was
saying about being a parent is like it's
interesting because children are so
present and especially when we have baby
babies not children all the time but yes
children as well
you're constantly present in the moment
because you're like i have to keep you
alive i have to keep you alive
and i would get nervous like well i have
to keep this human alive but it's all
being in the moment it's all present
that's right so nice also
another jesus quote oh jesus oh jesus
quote
[Laughter]
uh no i think oh jesus quote god i keep
i don't know what i'm doing to this poor
pillow but it's gonna smell like the
inside of me when i leave ask paul if in
sydney when the matches go off and he
goes it almost burned my dick
was that
intentional that he's he feels like a
castrated male and he's looking for a
father
can anyone help me with these paul
thomas anderson well why don't you call
him right now and ask him just give me
his math man
give me his math give me his man i've
never heard that before really in the bc
black community i'm a virgin
you're a virgin in the bc no i'm just a
virgin in general
i got whose phone number did i get it
was a blackberry oh it was chris redd
and i said give me your math do the
black people still say that and he
laughed really hard oh he's a lovely guy
yeah and i got confirmation that math is
still a thing in the bc well i wouldn't
know
because i was raised in westwood
save the theater save the mixed race
i don't know what that means save the
mixed race and save the man
don't say it again don't say it again
don't worry they're they're so they're
still on the david blaine thing oh yeah
so it happened twice it happened when
david blaine murdered somebody and it
happened when we talked about native
americans yes and and lineage
and our ancestors are you my ancestor
if you did text paul
was that because he's emasculated would
he what what emoji would he reply jk um
eggplant wait what
egg what here's
what were you asking about emojis
it was just a riff oh it's just a jazz
riff nobody wants to go back and explain
their riffs
no that's why we don't tweet anymore
we're just schuby dubin baby we're
scooby-doo and retro full circle i say
retro on a regular basis and we're full
cirque and it's
we're full cirque du
so soleil yeah were you yeah wow
um here's the last question
pta fart is written down there it does
fall it literally says pizza oh my god
oh because you have to ask him i won't
answer for yeah yeah but good news well
we really haven't i know the answer
you've smelt the answer and i've dealt
the answer
sometimes we say the case of the people
of smelt v dealt did you ever say silent
but deadly or silent but violent
i'd do both but i learned silent but
deadly that was the best did you ever
hear whoever smelt it dealt it and
whoever dealt it felt it because i just
heard for the first time in my life and
whoever dealt it felt it it was like
three weeks ago
i'm 43 someone said and whoever dealt it
felt it
i've never heard that and that's another
one of valencia we laugh about farts and
i'm like when you fart you kind of know
the shape of it oh my god because your
butt kind of goes like oh it's like it's
like you could do like a little sound
wave my farts are different since i've
had children for sure i'm sure
i mean because i got a
brand new butthole when i have a full
tire they rebuild you a butthole
they go we got a full tear oh god is
that crazy yeah and this is why the
exorcist is so scary when it's like and
they pee it's like we're so not okay
talking about full tears period panties
something about that peeing thing was
really just it was like oh something's
it's almost like she has a fever like
she's like something's wrong with my
child like and the way the mom looks at
her was really like oh no well the he
when i say humiliation i don't mean it
in a bad way the the the grounding
humbling thing of having a child like
that
i don't want to say that tearing but i'm
just like oh no
but like
that is a death experience this is why
you see a lot more uh enlightened women
than you do men period first of all
teaches cycle flow like you have to make
peace with your body boys are blowing
loads into
into socks left and right
but there
val
i've done weird psychedelics and stuff
and she just doesn't feel the need
because she pushed our baby out of here
yeah i definitely think that the some of
the
feet like the intensity the majority of
the intense feelings i was having was
fear of dying
while i was delivering and here you are
yeah that's it so if what if you thought
you couldn't live through it and you did
you must not be what you thought you
were mm-hmm right yeah that's nice
that's good it's around us
oh speaking of a guy in pain i was gonna
say you're really good at this but it
wasn't you that said that i remembered
it then you're really good at this
aren't you a healer
aren't you a
vessel of the holy ghost
that's
creepily accurate isn't it good that's a
but that was the first like daniel
plainview i feel like i've heard all day
it was good it was more than good
all day give me a good one
pete
can you imagine if i was like
i'm waving i just do fail again
that was one of my favorite moments
listen tell them
what's that
yeah
what is it pete
[Applause]
go on
petey
you know when i'm miking my eyeball
you're being very funny it's probably so
loud she's like she's she's having to
turn it oh no that's that's do you know
that when i record the hormone monsters
they have to turn it down everywhere
it's so loud of course it is it's so
loud what a thing you've done you saw
this is our mug maya didn't bring this
i had this made
you had it made no no no i had it etsy i
bought it on that seat
because there was no official that's
seize one
so there's no official merge is there
is are there mugs now
i mean based on kroll's house i think
there's some merch
i'm just kidding
uh
my my i haven't done nick roll in a
while
john mullane no wait wait you have a
nick roll i used to i'm ready
i can't do it anymore
when when you feel it brett gelman do
you know brett gilman i i know of brett
gilman i used to do brexit but see i
went john malini's a good friend of mine
and it was brett gelman that was my
touchstone for brett gilman it was john
milady is a really good friend of mine
yeah it's sort of closed the nose deep
closing those two
there's so many horrifically sounding
people that it's so good like they all
have like nasals yeah
a lot of andre the giant did he live
long no
my giant body is mostly gone is it was
it a thyroid condition i mean look
that's the best guess either one of us
is going to be i don't know it was it
was he was in pain too by the end he was
in pain i hate it when i hate it when
people are in pain or things but there's
a great story i don't know if it's a
great story but he's in a lot of pain
and he's wrestling hulk hogan it's like
one of his last matches and they had
choreographed it sorry but it's uh it's
not fake but it's choreography what i'm
not saying it's fake i'm saying it's
quirky you sure did
that was fake it's fake i'm not saying
it's me
i'm not i'm saying it's choreographed
it's quite real the pain is real well
that is true that's the part i don't
understand why do you choose to do
something that causes you pain because
it's like uh monster trucks but they're
the cars yikes right
and they choreographed it to be very
gentle to andre right
hulk was gonna win but they weren't
gonna because he was you know his body
was achy
understatement but then during the match
hulk tells a story in the documentary he
goes he hears andre go
slum
like he called it out meaning body slam
me because he's like you he's a live
performer and once the crowd was there
he was like they want to give it to me
then he said give it to me give it to me
mr rhino you want to say bonjour
come on over come on no i'll sit on my
lap i can't do it look billy crystal
it's billy crystal he's here
billy crystal
i love
the one about
mr sutherland
oh my god
i don't feel like i'll ever recuperate
from how good that impression of andre
the giant is you're reminding me of like
certain people when they do impressions
like i'm just like keep doing it i feel
like the person's here
i love it so much
i was drunk it was john mulaney's
wedding
oh no
it's okay it's okay yeah it's okay i'm
divorced too you made the number was
this your face that was the best part
i'm just saying i felt like i don't oh i
don't it's so weird we're all scared of
john because he's the best
so you're like don't make fun of john
but it's okay to be divorced exactly
yeah no one's
it was your face that was
but i drunkenly uh
somewhat drunkenly it's also just who i
am
beckoned bill hater over to just do
impressions with me i was like bill get
out of here
and he did it to his credit he did it he
did what he came over and did
impressions with me but i want to know
which impressions you guys did we did
them all really i think oh that's fine
but it was mike it was there i think and
he was like you shouldn't have done that
why like like he thought it was like
i think he was like it's bill hater you
don't do that and i was like come on man
people who do impressions love doing
that
honey you can do whatever you want
a lot of dead joggers in the park a lot
of dead joggers the the park is filled
with jet joggers um
my um my grandfather wrote a rap once
because my dad's a songwriter and so he
was like oh hey hotshot do so you think
you're such a hotshot do something with
this
and so
i'm sorry he challenged your dad to like
put a beat to it he said oh do something
with my lyrics yeah so he sent my dad um
it was at the time that ice-t had the
song cop killer yeah and now he's on the
back of my kid's chair cheerios box
going move with iced tea oh and i'm like
can we get cop killer playing over the
video being like we should let's move we
should teach our children the history of
iceland
iced tea
iced tea and snoop have really
they've made it all beautiful you're
absolutely right why am i teasing no no
because he grew
he grew he stopped killing oh but i
don't i mean it's it's it's it's his
history he's allowed he can be on the
back of a cheerios box he could be on
the back of
a tortilla chip bag i don't give a [__]
have a chips little bit of soy a lot of
flavor sorry they're a sponsor have you
had a habit yep they're my favorite
they're my favorite oh brands they're so
good the ones at the bottom they're my
favorite i'm sorry because they've got a
little extra bit of lime on them yeah
heaven isn't i like i like tang a lot i
like tangy taste and tostitos with lime
taste like green froot loops next time
you have them i just had tostitos with
lime and i thought they tasted like
doritos and they were delicious they are
delicious but when you eat them next go
green fruit loop and you'll go oh my god
flanny does look like shawn aston it'll
be one of those moments but flanny
really does look like no sorry sean
astin does look like flanny
uh don't remember what i was saying
and i refused to acknowledge it i was
like anyway my eyes are over here
um wait why was i oh cop killer right
rudolph sent my dad lyrics that he wrote
called reply to a cop killer and it goes
a little something like this hit it well
you dress like a million but you act
like [__] so don't bug me take a hike
take a hike take a hike
it didn't rhyme nope
i was waiting for take a [__] didn't
need to
you dress like a million but you act
like [__] so don't bug me
oh sorry so don't bug me get off my back
take a hike take a hike take a hike and
did your dad
frame it yeah
yeah he did
i mean
there it's wonderful
i'm in love with your family yeah can i
eat with the weird ones yes they're a
lot of fun they're around
they're available i mean they're not in
l.a but we can get you on a plane
i can be on a plane
i'll be on johnny mitchell's plane
watching
bridesmaids full [__] circles making
my own face hi i'm full [__] circle
home it's my job to listen intently for
three hours and then not the rest of the
day
cut to me with my daughter hey lucy
you're gonna take like a hot nap after
this because it's like so much happening
i didn't but i'm about to that's me oh
my god i want to do it i would love to
do a hot tub called circle of paradise
because i have a hot tub and a cold
plunge and if you go between those do
you do it you get high as [__] do you
really do the cold plunge after the hot
tub i do the cold punch first because
i'm a [__] pirate
so did you do
does your brain feel wonderful
the word is clear you just feel still
and clear and we call it fbj full body
jizz because if you get in really cold
water and then get in really hot water
your whole body it's like you are pop
rocks it feels incredible
you're you're diet coke and here come
the [__] mentos
all right here comes i need to do it i
mean well i've always wanted to do the
cold plunge but now i think i have to
really set it up that way that you're
talking about well the coldplanche.com
promo code weird at checkout fbj
fbj
fbj it's serious i mean you could do it
but you'd probably feel weird
doing it in your backyard while you're
like picking up your kid from school
yeah i would
you know
we've had parties where people get it
parties is different if i was invited
that's different have a few cocktails
having a mocktail
having a mai tai having a mai tai having
a your tie okay oh my god we've
officially run out of steam here's the
last question yes
can you tell me the time in your life
you laughed the hardest you've you've
never laughed that hard was that
supposed to be prepared
and it doesn't have to be a good story
but come on kay wig
is there she's putting a lemon in her
teeth sure uh willie farrer he's showing
you his chest um someone fell someone
farted
um one of your kids came in and and
pooped on the floor it doesn't have to
be a good story all of these things have
happened of course
but like i'll give you a hand because i
don't want you to feel on the spot it's
not that kind of thing it's just like
i remember one time i said to valley go
do something that's never we were in the
bowery hotel
i go do something that's never been done
before and as i started
i already know that something happened
and i start spinning and my pants fall
down
i trip i'm too tall i hit my head on the
lamp like the the ceiling lamp and then
i hit on the bed and then val laughs so
hard she farted and it's the best and we
just died it's so that is a good one but
i mean like they don't have to be like
and then i open the door and who is it
joe pesci it doesn't have to be like
that
just
who who are you laughing you said
do something that's not someone's
getting
do something that's never been done like
i'm trying to be novel and interested
oh god
do something that's never been done
just maybe you were a kid can you
remember a time when you laughed real
hard when you were a kid yes i'm sure
see this is what happens if i laugh too
hard sometimes then it turns and then i
can't stop it yes oh i love it so much i
can also just this is a fine way to end
would you want to just what if i was
like no
no i can't i have no recall
i feel like well definitely definitely
bridesmaids days we were all um laughing
pretty hard
god i know
i know that there's something here
that's gonna that's gonna
pop into my mind when i drive
oh it's okay away let's not do that do
you wanna hear my jet impression yeah
maya i just wanna see maybe maybe we
could do it another time
maybe christian knock over the heart
girl it's not even that good i didn't i
wasn't aware of how many impressions you
did like they're all just coming up
bridesmaids
crowd apatow we call him crud credit
cred credit using cred like his
screen credit he's got real he's got
real credit
sometimes i just look at judd's imdb
just to be like i don't have time to
read all this oh my god oh my god maya i
want to give you an award it's the best
episode of all time
um
you're welcome to keep that mug yeah you
can keep that mud i know that's not true
but i really do appreciate it because
it's so fun i knew i would love you
because of the way that you laugh so i
had a feeling it was going to be it was
going to be a fun day yeah the screws
are loose in the good way yeah well yes
and not even in a crazy way just i was
like oh that's a fun laugh and even a
laugh that i can relate to a little bit
yeah cause you got that it's real it's
it's a i got a little witchcackle what's
your favorite movie
that's the better or last question
not pta
let's just take it off the table i'm
kidding dig it off the p table i have
favorites but i don't have a favorite
okay i'm sorry that's okay i'm just
trying to give you a do i like reggie
music is that the next question is this
a [__] date pete um i'm gonna say
i mean when i was growing up i loved i
told you john hughes movies of course
like i knew all the words to all the
well 16 candles but that doesn't count
yes i'm going to say and and revenge of
the nerds i know all the words yes but
i'm going to say like um
nerdier ones i really
when i was little i loved
mommy dearest
mommy dead and dearest on hbo no mommy
dearest the joan crawf the um joan
crawford movie that um faye dunaway
played joan crawford and she was a
horrible mother loved it oh yeah
super weird because it was on tv we had
the z channel here which was kind of an
anomaly and it was like it was basically
like the new art in your home it would
show uncensored movies weird strange
arty arthouse movies yeah okay um
i really loved victor victoria it's a
blake edwards movie with
his wife i don't know that one yeah
cause i'm a [__] i love um
uh what's that diane keaton movie where
she moves to the country
yeah that one
um
oh my god i can't think
you you name three already you're not my
favorite you know what one movie that i
love
every day i'm like oh yeah that is one
of my favorite movies
beetlejuice
yeah
it's don't say it two more times but yes
what if i believed i'm a believer
no it's also dark it is dark catherine
cherry that killed herself and all that
sort of stuff it's like oh yeah with the
split i believe catherine o'hara oh it's
there but the smoke is coming out of her
neck
oh that lady killed herself yeah but the
lady that smoke yeah she's got the slit
and then it starts talk about a time
nobody was uh keeping too close of an
eye on old tim burt you know what i mean
they sure were not making dumbo's ears
but boy oh boy that original timber that
that bert timber and the peewee's big
adventure tim bert
yep
large marge pure magic tim burton ernie
i just learned something about burton
ernie i know you want to end but that a
lot of it um
all the burton ernie stuff was
improvised i know you want to end yeah
yeah they're riffing
yeah and two good friends that are
riffing which is good why and so
well i mean the the puppet is your eye
okay
what happened to your eye
i just feel like nothing nobody takes me
seriously everybody thinks i'm implying
no no no no no no no i tried to get a
withdrawal from my bank i was like i
want to take out some phones no it's
great you're doing great i don't know
i feel like i shouldn't rob a bank with
you i feel like you would give yourself
away
do you wink with your left or your right
i believe
yeah i think i'm more
i think i'm more on my right you ever do
a devil
no i more left
this is what i did to jodie mitchell
see you around
that was good though the first one you
did was more labeled labored it was like
because it was my right my left is my my
left is my good wink god help us we hope
you winked right to joni mitchell and
one last time
journal ritual i still don't understand
the reference he gives her a journey
mitchell cd
and he speaks that way because he's
because he's all alan allen oh is it
alan cummings
i said alan come here helen cummings
oh my god that's a different voice
alan rickman i mean alan [__] yeah
i don't know if i can't do it i'm just
saying it doesn't sound like alan
rickman
no unless he well that's a nick roll bit
alan rickman always sounds like he had a
glass of milk like he just finished a
big glass what what is your nick crawl
did you ever find it no what was it
god he's so [__] funny
nick he used to say like um
what was it
he would say go get that booty smack him
lay her down and smack him yack him
i can do voices that he does on the show
i kind of feel that that was my where my
brain went too but his voice
i can't because he's not a real human
did you not know that
he's a comedy robot he's he's completely
comro he's a he's a comrade because he's
so perfect
yeah not the nick i know oh boy i just
stare into the middle distance oh
you've seen that you've gone to some
dark places
you've seen you've seen it all
let's just say i saw him at john
mulaney's wedding
[Laughter]
okay peter we did it
rudy
yes petey my
yes pete yeah yeah
yeah yeah no one's ever called me yeah
yet it just happened we got paul tom and
yaya and now would you please say
keep it crispy
would you do it as a hormone monster you
will
you don't mind no you were ready no but
i just thought about it
okay ready
keep it crispy
one more time
hey pete keep it crispy
not good enough it was excellent it's
because you don't have your cans on you
oh do you think that's why i think those
sound great
next time i'm at your house i'm going to
keep it crispy
then i walk away and there's an ice
block
you have shined today
go home and say
two things
paul tom i shined today yes where's the
three-hour cut
i will and you know what um paul said to
me when we woke up this morning are you
doing pete holm's podcast today no cause
i put it in the calendar cute
so somebody's
somebody's on somebody's radar you can
wiggle my big toe
is this one longer than this it's the
coup de toe
some people have a second one that's
longer i do not
oh
i'm very clearly an [__] that's why
you got him in those hookahs
that's what paul calls them
hookahs
hocas
let's go let's go with hookah okay let's
when i when i remember when i laughed so
hard that i like i just urinated myself
profusely can i can i tell you can i
email you you can voice message me and
then we'll play it on the show
really of course
oh
so smart
i thought you were kind of like
i'm like turned on you're like oh oh i
can record my own voice really
like two old people that have forgotten
what sex is
oh
the way you slice that bread or that's
just people that are turned on my food i
don't know i sadly think
that's probably me it is me thank you
mike thank you petey that was really fun
that's great okay i guess i'll go
[Music]
be